Hello, everybody!
I'm sorry I'm a little late.
I literally... I went outside.
How could I do this to you guys?
I touched grass!
Sorry, I went out... I touched some grass today, so...
I've been touching grass a lot, guys, and I literally just got back, like, five minutes ago.
Like, 2.05, I got back, and I was like, and I was like, turning everything on, getting everything done.
I was like, oh my gosh, did they post a code yet?
Oh, thank God they didn't.
Okay, so we're good to go.
We're okay.
I haven't even... guys, I haven't even eaten lunch yet.
I touched grass, but I didn't even eat yet.
It's okay, I can survive.
I have... I have lots of snacks.
I have some snacks in my room for emergency.
Moments like this, so it'll be okay, guys.
Sorry, I've been... we're busy.
Well, not busy.
I've been sleeping and touching grass.
I've been going outside and doing stuff.
Um, but we are at day two!
Give it up for day two of Fortnite Twitch Rivals!
There's a lot of rules for day two.
Um...
Okay.
Alright.
There's a lot.
There's like two paragraphs.
Like, it's like two pages.
I was looking at it, and I was just like, what the...
What the fuck?
Okay, let me tell you guys what the new rules are.
So, for the second format, the second format of this tournament, it is, um...
It's complicated.
It's very complicated.
So, um, basically each game is different.
It's like a different thing.
And, um...
It has like different rules.
So, they ban certain...
They ban certain...
How am I gonna keep...
I barely know it
now!
Okay, anyway.
Um, in some of the games...
Sorry, I just found out at the same time as you guys.
Um...
I literally just found out.
Like, right now.
Anyway.
Um...
Okay.
Ian Todd didn't read the rules.
Because I'm reading it.
As we go along.
Sorry, out of anger, I choked.
Out of anger...
I choked on my own saliva.
Okay, now.
Sorry.
I found out they ban certain guns for each game.
Each game is different!
Each game...
There's certain bans...
For certain guns.
Oh, God.
My throat is so fucked right now after so much anger.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
Rules fucked me up.
I fucking hate rules.
Alright.
Okay.
So!
Game one.
They have this thing called hotspots.
Hotspot landing.
They also have this thing called safe zone.
So, safe zone is off.
What do you mean by safe zone?
Well...
Each game...
There's a...
There's a certain rule.
If safe zone is on, you cannot kill until the storm hits the second storm.
So, nobody is allowed to kill until it's storm two.
But, in game one...
Safe zone is off.
But what do you mean by safe zone is off?
Also, what the fuck is wrong with my monitor?
Like...
No!
Why is everything fucked up?
Guys, I'm...
It's going to look a little weird soon.
My monitor is weird.
I need to turn it on and off.
Give me a sec.
Everything is going to look weird for a sec.
Because I need to turn on my...
Turn my on and off my monitor.
Anyway.
So!
Okay.
Now, my monitor is not turning on.
Wait.
Why is my monitor not turning on?
What's going on?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I was going to be really worried.
I was...
Oh, no.
What's going on?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Everything is okay now.
Okay, guys.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
I'm a little bit of a mess, guys.
I'm...
I'm a little bit of...
Is it noticeable that I'm a little bit of a mess?
Is it...
Is it noticeable at all?
Actually...
I don't know.
Um...
Anyway...
Games...
So, what I mean by safe zone?
So, like I said, the moment it hits...
The first game has no safe zone.
But it has, like, a hot drop.
So, like, if you land in this hot drop area, you get...
Each member gets 1 point.
But the thing is, there's no safe zone so people can kill.
So there can be, like, 30 people in this one...
In this one area.
Just for the whole game.
What are those two points?
So we're landing there?
So we're gonna be landing there.
For those two points.
Anyway, game two!
There's gonna be...
Game two?
We're allowing cars for game two.
Oh, it's Fortnite.
Fortnite's why it's fucking weird.
Oh, okay.
Fortnite's the reason why everything's flashing.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good at all.
Why is...
Why is Fortnite flashing my monitor on and off?
Hello?
Fortnite?
Guys, I have a little problem.
Fortnite is currently flashing my game.
Flashing my monitor on and off.
I don't know how to fix this.
No, wait.
Is it okay?
Okay, it's okay now.
Alright, I...
Okay, I just can't tab out.
Okay, that's good.
Anyway...
Game two!
Game two?
There's gonna be cars.
So they're gonna allow car weapons.
So people are gonna be driving around in cars.
That's... I mean, there's a lot more to game two.
I was reading it and there's a lot more, but you're allowed to deal damage and kill with cars.
You can have car weapons.
Um...
There's a lot of consumables that you can use.
You can use shield breaker EMP.
What the fuck?
Um...
Let's see.
So there's that.
Game three?
Normal game.
Game three is a normal game.
Game four!
Safe zone is on.
So you can't deal... You can't kill anybody until the second storm.
And there's banned weapons.
There's a list of banned weapons.
I'm looking through them right now and I don't understand.
I barely understand, like, half... I barely understand more than two of the weapons in Fortnite.
Like, know the names of two of the weapons in Fortnite, let alone, like, all of this.
Um, and in game five...
Oh my god, there's six games.
Okay.
It's another hotspot landing where we're supposed to land on this random... this area called Brutal Beachhead.
That's the only rule.
That's the hotspot.
There's no safe zone.
And finally, the last game.
More banned weapons.
I have no...
There are new weapons too, by the way.
There's new weapons that are banned.
I still have no idea what those weapons are, but...
But, they're banned!
So, like, that's all the information I got.
Well, I should... I should have been joining a party.
Alright, nice.
Alright, so those are the new rules.
Oh my gosh, I'm not choking anymore.
Thank god.
How will I know if I have a bad weapon?
I don't know.
I'll just be like... I'll just be like, Doryu, I'm holding this weapon.
Is this banned?
That's like the only information.
If Nitro Fists are allowed, try to always get one.
I think they are.
I don't see any rules banning Nitro Fists.
That's the thing.
Oh, another announcement.
Oh, they changed something.
Oh wait, no.
Oh no, that's the code.
Okay, I was gonna be like, did they change something?
No, okay.
Nitro Dome.
Somebody asked if fists are allowed.
If game one and three...
Oh.
Fists are allowed, by the way.
They're only banned in game two.
So yes.
Lobby code's up.
Alright, gotta enter it for us though.
Did you...
Oh wait, am I leading?
Wait, are you leading?
No, no, you joined on me.
Oh, you're like...
Okay, I was gonna be like, oh god.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Are you writing a gremlin against me?
Okay, did you see the rules where it said that fists are allowed?
Wait, fists are allowed?
Yeah.
Oh, they're gonna have the fists in?
Yeah, they said it's not banned.
Okay, okay, alright.
So like... I guess we're gonna be fisting dudes?
Oh, okay.
I feel like...
Okay, first off, we gotta survive the fucking hot drop.
Okay, we're gonna survive, hot drop, and then we're gonna fist dudes.
Okay, you're gonna fist some dudes.
I'm just gonna watch.
I'm just...
You're gonna turn other people into werewolves.
Hey, wait.
Fisting turns dudes into werewolves?
Did that not turn you into a werewolf?
Wait, how did you know?
Who gave you those tapes?
Wait, is that how people turn into werewolves?
Is that not it?
How else is this gonna happen?
American Werewolf in London, the plot was all started because a dude got fisted, and then he turned into a werewolf.
Wait, is that true?
Yes.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
That's why there's not a lot of werewolves around.
That's why, like, they need to bring back some fists.
Like, fisting is so, like...
Gotta repopulate the werewolf population.
Yeah.
This is why we're gonna spread the word of fisting.
No, you're gonna spread the word of fisting.
I'm just...
I'm just a bystander.
You're gonna be suspended.
I'm here to fucking...
I'm just a bystander here.
I just learned.
No, there is no I in team.
Only us in fisting.
Wait, is there an us in fisting?
Yeah, you know.
Wait, no, there's no you?
Where the fuck's the you?
It's... it's fusty.
Wait, what combos can we be running today?
Combos?
Okay.
Except for this one.
Do you have a banana skin?
No, I don't, sadly.
Okay.
I do not, but I do have...
Okay, what matches with John Cena?
Because we haven't run... John Cena?
We didn't run John... did we run John Cena?
In... Not in the tournament.
No, we didn't run... Yeah, we didn't run John Cena in the tournament.
What matches with John Cena?
You have the most skins, so it's easier for you to... It's easier for you to match with me.
Should I be...
an employee?
Wait, who would go with John Cena?
Chad, who's gonna go with John Cena?
You guys gotta help us.
Uh... Who would go with John Cena?
Hmm... I'm like...
I'm going through all these.
I see, like, John Wick, John Cena... John The John... John is a sweaty skin, though.
John Cena and John Wick.
There's a big candy cane that...
A big ca- What does that have to do with... What does that have to do with John Cena?
Wait, put John Wick on for now.
Just for Team Johns!
Team Johns!
Team Johns?
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Wait, this is Terminator?
Yeah, but what does that have to do with John Cena?
Has Arnold Schwarzenegger ever wrestled?
I know he used to be an oiled up, buff man.
No, he used to be like a...
He used to be like a gym rat.
Like he would just... like he was like a gym trainer.
A bodybuilder.
Oh, okay, so he was a bodybuilder.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
To some degree, like John Cena is that.
But...
But he was more so of a wrestler.
Yeah, that's true, that's true.
Wait, do you not have The Rock?
Oh, that's what The Rock is?
I don't have him.
You don't have him?
Oh, that would have been perfect if we had John Cena and The Rock.
No, if I had The Rock, I would definitely run The Rock, yeah.
Yeah, that would have been perfect.
I wish you could like give skins you own.
I know, right?
Like just like a little share thing or whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But then like, but then Fortnite would never make money because people just like gift each other the skins back to back.
Oh my god.
Today I want to use this skin.
Can you gift that to me?
You share this one and I'll share this one back?
It seems fine.
Wait, what are you gonna use for your like...
I have pom-poms so I can cheer people up.
Yeah, yeah, and I have my wrestling belt.
My WWE champion title.
I don't think I have a wrestling belt.
Oh, I have a dumbbell I can use.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get a dumbbell.
Yeah, get us a dumbbell.
Wait, do I...
I think that's a back-wing too?
Uh...
I forgot I can have a dog on my back.
Oh!
Oh, no!
You should have the dog!
John Wick's dog!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
John Wick's dog!
Yeah!
Alright, I got John Wick's dog on.
I got his dog on.
Oh my god, yeah!
That's perfect!
Oh my god.
Have you seen it?
Have you seen it yet?
Yeah, yeah, you can pet it too!
You pet the dog!
Yeah, I fucking love that one.
I forgot I had that.
Let's go, I'm gonna motivate us.
Let's go, everybody!
We're here!
Team John!
Let's go, guys!
Let's go!
Wait, what's your glider?
What glider are you using?
My glider is... oh, it's just the same.
Shenron.
Okay, you're using Shenron.
Yeah, I really don't have any good gliders or...
uh...
I don't have any good gliders or trails.
I never buy gliders.
No, gliders are like...
I usually get them on the Battle Pass.
I don't think I ever really spend money on them.
I've like bought like a few.
Yeah, I don't buy Battle Pass, I just...
I never buy Battle Pass.
Wait, oh my god, did my game crash?
Did my game crash because I looked at the Battle Pass?
Are you...
Yeah, it's frozen because I looked at it!
Oh shit!
No!
I'm missing one team.
No, no, I can't believe it!
It crashed because I looked...
That's the sign.
That's the sign where it's like...
You literally can't tap into anything else!
Wait, I can cancel Q.
I can cancel.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, it literally crashed because of the Battle Pass!
What are the chances?
I need to get Task Manager out!
Danny, are you trying to play with your Johns?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, the rock was a Battle Pass skin?
I don't remember.
Oh my god, oh my god.
That took like forever to fucking close.
That's actually okay.
I'm gonna fucking put my Task Manager on the side just in case.
Okay, today's a mess.
It's okay, I'm a mess too.
Today's a mess right now.
Okay, welcome back to normal people hours.
What's wrong with me?
I hear you.
I saw you played more Fortnite right after.
I actually played so much Fortnite last night.
Yeah, you actually practiced.
Me practice?
Oh my god, you actually practiced.
I know my place in this tournament.
I know my place too.
Everyone's like, you know the lobby's stacked?
I'm like, yeah, we felt it was stacked yesterday.
Yeah, I was like, cause I was like asking Twitch, I was like, are there teams that are like me?
And there's like, yeah, yeah, there are.
There's like, and then he listed like four teams.
I was like, oh, okay.
Those, okay.
I didn't realize there was like more than, you know, I was like, oh yeah, okay.
Four teams that are just like me, okay.
But then like, I don't think they were like me.
We are the one and only.
No one else can be like us.
I don't think they were like me.
Are we the only VTubers in the whole tournament?
I think so.
I think all the other VTubers said no.
The other VTubers are like, I don't know man.
Do I wanna get like absolutely demolished by like Fortnite players?
And I, obviously I I have no sense of self-worth, so I was like, yeah, let's do it.
You hit up the right person to fill last minute.
Cause like, me and Fortnite is so carefree that I'm like, I don't, I know I'm not gonna play this game competitively.
I know I can apply myself, like I could play competitively.
Yeah, I was like, you know what, $125 is $125.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Like, you know what, $125, I'm fine with that.
Like, I, I...
Oh shit, you still have your crown?
How do you still... I won my last game.
How do you still...
Okay.
Okay, so we're gonna land, we're landing here.
We're landing here.
There's the Nitro Dome, that's it, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna land on the outside of the Nitro.
Yeah, I think we just land on the outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright chat, game number one, let's fucking go!
I dropped?
I don't know.
I'm dropping out.
Yeah, I don't know if that's too much.
No, that's fine.
That's actually fine.
Cause I know, like, it's the outskirt.
You just have to land on the outskirt and you're fine.
Yeah, yeah.
As long as, like, there's actually, um...
I'm trying to think what side's safer.
I think this side's better?
I don't know.
There's a lot of people that have the same plan as us.
So I don't know.
Look at all these people landing on the outskirts!
Can people, like, kill us right away or no?
Yeah, yeah, they can, they can, they can.
Oh shit!
Okay, wait, we land together, right?
Yeah, where are you landing?
I'm landing right here, I'm landing right here.
Okay, okay, I'll land here.
Oh my god.
Wait, can I use my gun yet?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can't instantly, you can't instantly.
Okay, I got a gun, I got a gun, I got a gun.
There's people below you, there's people below you.
Okay.
Alright, I landed.
I leave you.
Do you have a gun?
Goodbye.
No.
I left.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
I'm out.
I'm poking out.
Somebody instantly grabbed a car and they fucking booked it.
Wait, what's over there?
It's down here.
I might die.
Oh.
Oh shit, this guy is zooming.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Oh, there's a guy on you?
Yeah, there's a guy on me.
Oh, there's cars, there's so many cars.
Oh my god.
Are you sure we can kill him?
I'm scared, I'm really scared.
I'm so scared.
I went up the zip.
I'm really scared.
There were cars trying to run me over.
Where are you?
I'm below you.
Okay, I looted some potion.
Okay, let's leave.
Let's fucking go.
I almost had several cars trying to run me over.
There is a vehicle that spawns over here that we can grab?
You have a gun, right?
Yeah, I have two guns.
That was some Mad Max shit right there.
Go through this, uh...
Go through the little ring.
Oh my god.
Are they here?
No, we're good, we're good.
There's no car here, but we're good.
We can live.
Okay, we can live for a little bit.
Oh, I got a Flowberry Fizz, whatever that fucking shit is.
It's like a big jizz bottle or whatever.
Oh, do we need that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, use it, use it right now.
Click and hold, click and hold.
Woo!
Let's go!
You're gonna be okay!
Alright.
Do you need more?
No, you're fine.
No, no, I'm good, I'm good.
Okay.
Do you have any movement?
Do you want more shockwaves?
No, I... Wait, actually I do.
What am I holding?
I'm holding a shield breaker.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna drop it too.
I gotta get the shockwaves.
Oh, the EMPs?
Those stop vehicles like instantly.
Oh, then we should get that, right?
They're really good.
I don't know.
People are gonna play this first round.
That's the only thing I'm, like, unsure about.
I don't even know if people are gonna play any of the rounds.
Alright, one person's dead dead.
Oh.
I'm glad it's not us!
Yeah!
Thank fucking God!
Oh, there's...
I got more nitro splashes.
The, um, infinite I have no idea what gun I have.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, wait, what's this?
Remote explosives.
Oh, there's a car coming through?
Oh.
They're coming to us.
Wait...
Right over here.
I think they're gone.
Oh!
Magneto gloves!
Huge!
Oh, that's good!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, do you wanna try them?
No, no, no.
That's fine.
I don't think I...
You should give me any power.
I'm gonna drop...
Should I have magneto gloves?
I'm kinda worried about that.
I feel like maybe I shouldn't have.
Oh, I'm so unsure what to carry right now.
I don't know, like...
It's okay.
We already got two points.
Oh, that's true.
We did.
We already automatically got two points.
That's alright.
Uh, do you wanna carry the Gibby domes?
Uh, Gibby bullets?
Oh, yeah.
Sure.
There's, uh, some here, and then there's nitros here.
Uh, do we want nitros or dome?
Um...
I have nitros, actually.
You can carry domes.
Okay, I'll get domes.
I'll just use them on us.
Yeah.
And then, um... Damn, like, I'm unsure of, like, what weapons to use.
Uh, cause, like, I think people are gonna play for zone, mostly?
So... I mean, are we in... We're...
We are in zone at the moment, so...
We're chillin' right now, yeah.
Yeah, we're chillin' here.
Only one person's died, which is very scary.
Damn.
Um...
Man, I'm such a scuffler.
You wanna keep looting, or you wanna chill?
Uh, I don't mind either.
You know what?
Let's go... Let's go...
Oh, wait.
Is the bus starting by?
I'm gonna chill here for a sec.
Oh, is that a battle bus?
Uh, no.
It's, uh...
It's, uh, NPCs.
Oh, okay.
It is a battle bus, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You think somebody's on it?
I just...
What are they doing?
Oh, they're just, like, rotating.
That's so weird.
Is that somebody on that battle bus?
No, it's NPCs.
It's all NPCs.
Okay, okay.
Um... Oh, they got rebooted!
Wait, nobody's dead!
Nobody died in the grand party?
In the Nitro Dome?
How's that possible?
You wanna go to Pleasant?
You wanna go over here?
Sure.
Alright, let's try to get, like, more looted.
I'm gonna burn a Nitro on us?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just surprised nobody died!
Oh my god, I'm gonna say that and then we're gonna die.
Should be able to take fall damage here.
Or no fall damage, I mean.
And then... I don't know if it's looted here or not.
I saw a car over there, but I don't know if that's the battle bus.
Oh, it's the battle bus.
Yeah, we're good.
Oh, it is looted here.
Okay, so there might be someone here.
Be very careful.
Okay.
I'm gonna head to you.
Ape strong together.
Ape strong!
John strong together.
Alright, let's keep on clearing the buildings together.
Oh yeah, it's, like, super looted.
Oh, there's more domes here?
Oh, nice.
The one thing you're gonna notice is that the bunkers aren't, or the houses, aren't as common here either.
That's good.
That's good to know.
On, uh, normal mode.
Oh, the chest is above?
Oh, it's upstairs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got it.
Oh, med kit.
We need it.
See, I'm not carrying any heal.
I should probably carry heals over the It's also cabbages.
Oh, we do have cabbages.
I think it's gonna be one of the heal items, I think, in one of the games.
Oh.
Oh, people fighting?
Yeah, I hear gunshots.
I really want to, like, mess Oh, there's houses here.
I guess I should probably carry the houses.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
House equals win.
I'm carrying the houses.
Oh, there's EMPs.
Wait.
They're driving by.
Yeah, I hear shots.
I hear shots.
Yeah.
I'm going to...
I hear lots of shots.
Yeah, I'm gonna see if I...
On me, on me, on me, on me, on me, on me.
Right here.
I'm looking.
They're on me, on me.
Holy shit, I think they're above me.
Oh, they are above.
I might be dead.
I'm actually going to shockwave.
I'm shockwaving away.
Shockwave yourself towards me if you can.
Okay, I don't know if they know I'm here.
I don't think they do.
I think I'm dead.
I'm, like, getting hardchased right now.
Holy shit!
They went for you?
Yup.
No!
Of course they have gloves and shockwaves.
I literally have no shockwave.
Oh, no, they have Magneto gloves.
Actually, you can chill.
You can chill.
Okay.
They don't know about you.
Yeah, they don't know about you.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
I didn't know!
Wait, what?
What?
I was literally in the corner!
I'm so confused!
I am so confused, too.
I wanna, like, just watch replays.
See, like, how they did it.
How did they know I was there?
I'm so confused.
What the fuck?
Where is this teammate?
So, they had the vehicle, and then they were just driving around?
But, like, were they baiting people?
Or... I'm so confused.
What?
How did he know?
That's so unfortunate that the first medallion we came across is the most busted one.
Cause that's the...
It's the Nitro medallion, where it gives you unlimited Nitro.
Oh!
So he has unlimited Nitro.
Yeah.
I'm just like...
How did they, like, find you the moment you were just, like, hiding there, right?
Yeah!
Wait, does the medallion show where I am?
No, uh-uh.
What?
I...
I am so confused.
I wanna, like, go back and replay.
I just don't understand.
I just... I actually don't understand.
I just wanna know what happened.
But he was just in the corner!
And he fucking blew up the exact house I was in!
That's why I'm, like, so confused.
Like, did you... I mean, like, they knew you were alive, right?
Yeah, but they blew up the one house I was in.
That was so confusing.
Wait, what?
They smelled... They... Oh.
The more medallions you have...
But... Oh, no, but I didn't have the medallions.
I didn't.
Yeah, Yogi did not have it, though.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I didn't have it.
That's why I was, like, how did he find out?
Yeah.
I just... I gotta see!
I'm, like, so confused!
Yeah!
I'm just, like, I thought I was... I thought I was safe!
That's why I didn't move!
Okay, so...
So I'm getting chased.
Understandable.
Are you watching the replay now?
Yeah.
You know, this is...
That's when I know I knew my place.
Were you crouched the whole time?
Yeah, you were literally... Yeah!
Wait, what?
What?
He literally goes straight for you!
Wait, what?
Uh...
Are you watching my POV right now?
No.
Oh.
What?
Huh?
You're not even exposed for anything!
Wait.
Okay, before I get killed...
Let's see...
Okay, so I'm shock waving.
Maybe they saw me go in that room and they just assumed I never left.
Yeah, that could have been the case, yeah.
I think that's... that's really the only thing I could, like, imagine.
Oh my god!
Wait, why are they going to the store?
Oh, because they're trying to find the medallion person?
Oh, no, they just wanted gas.
Okay, I was like...
I was like, why are they in the store?
They just wanted gas.
Holy shit, that's so fucking...
Fortnite gamers, man.
Oh, you know what it was?
What?
So, um, they probably saw your footsteps.
And then...
Yeah, and then you wanted to crouch, but like...
They just went straight back to the building probably because that's the last place that they saw you.
But I could have left!
I know, right?
I could... how did they... I could have left!
I...
I'm, like, very, very confused.
Oh my god!
Fortnite gamers.
This is why condoms games deserve nothing.
They deserve nothing.
Okay, wait, what's weird?
Okay, this is the weird part.
The only weird part is that he goes straight for your room.
Like, he doesn't even, like, just tackle the building.
He goes straight for the room.
What the fuck?
I got red so well.
And you're, like, crouched here.
What the fuck?
If only we know who they are.
They're all not in this mode.
I mean, like, I can see what it is in the kill... or in, uh, in replay.
No, no, wait, who is it?
Maybe you can just see what how they... they must have calmed out or something.
Yeah, they probably... they probably just calmed it.
They probably calmed it.
They're probably, like, I think they're in the building?
And then they're like, wait, what the fuck?
He's right here or whatever, you know?
That's probably what they were saying.
Fucking coward.
That's fucking crazy.
Unlucky.
Oh my god.
Bro, this...
I think this game mode is worse than yesterday.
It's just very unlucky, because, like, our first medallion is the most broken one.
And... I guess, like, theoretically, we could have kept arriving.
Like, the first one we face?
Or their...
Yeah, the first one that we face is, like, the most broken medallion.
Oh my god.
I thought they were supposed...
Bro, this guy's just literally...
Does this car not have HP?
Like, can it ram into everything?
I don't... Yeah, that's a...
It's a boss car.
So, when they get the...
the boss car, then, um, it has, like, more HP.
And then it also goes faster.
It basically is an overtune vehicle.
In, like, every way.
Oh...
What the fuck?
Are they just gonna win?
Are they not?
Brother!
It feels like they have, like, the most busted shit!
He's literally driving around everywhere.
I think we should...
Yeah, we definitely should have got a car.
Okay, so, like, one person is using the gloves.
Yeah, because it's allowed.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've... Yeah, see, I was thinking, like, oh, I'm gonna use the...
Magneto gloves.
And then I can just, like, damage cars.
Because it's really good against vehicles.
Ah...
If they're not banned, then I'm just gonna keep on trying to... Oh my god!
It just depends on how aggressive we're playing.
Bro, this guy knows where all the fucking places to go!
I feel like if we just had a car, we could just drive around and not care.
Like, we don't have to worry about rotation.
Yeah.
I mean, the first... It's really weird with, like, these rulesets, because it's, like, very random.
And I think it's...
They're just trying to, like, capitalize on just, like, alright, make it chaotic and all that stuff, but it sucks even more when it's, uh...
People would get good RNG on already very chaotic modes.
Yeah.
Wait, so we...
In second mode, there's safe zone, so we could just grab a car somewhere.
Does our drop have a car?
Yeah!
Um, so I got us a drop spot, um, outside of the safe zones.
Okay.
So...
Our, uh, drop spot doesn't have a vehicle... Actually, no, it has two vehicles.
I lied.
There's one, like... Yeah, we can just get a vehicle and just drive away.
Yeah, yeah.
And just survive with a car.
Because I feel that's how... that's how people are surviving.
Yup.
Oh, they got EMP?
Oh, that's smart.
Wait, who?
Bubble shields.
I'm, like, watching the Twitch Rivals POV right now, because I backed out of the game because I wanted to see, like, the...
the replay.
I'm just watching the car, people.
I think they're gonna win.
They seem like the type of team... What?
How?
What?
Did they get EMP?
No, they, like, instantly shot that bush, so I'm just like, how did they know?
Never trust a bush.
You see a bush, you're just like, well... Holy shit.
Yeah, but he was so paranoid.
He, like, he got a car just to shoot at that bush.
I was like, I guess they know this map so well, and they're like, there's no bush.
It's like, it's like those hide and seek, um, like, in Gmod, like, hide and seek, where people, like... No, prop hunt.
It's like prop hunt.
Yeah, yeah, where they're like, I know this map, like, the back of my hand.
So they're like, what is this random bush doing here?
At X100004 Y430, there's never a bush there.
So then he's like, that's sus.
It's like prop hunt.
I think that's a player.
Fucking shoot it.
It's literally those prop hunt hunters who play the same map 100 million times so they know exactly where's what.
It's basically Fortnite.
Fortnite is everyone is literally a prop and you just shoot it.
I'm just kinda thinking that now.
Cause, like, there was like, there was no indication that there, like, it was just this random bush and the moment they saw that bush, they went out and shot it.
Damn.
Wait, really?
They just, like, hopped down and was like, what?
Yeah, the guy literally got off the car just to shoot that random bush and then me and my chat was like, question mark?
What?
What the...
Hey, I gotta, like, I wanna see your POV now.
Cause, like, I'm not watching the match anymore.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, that's why I'm so confused.
The fact that this man got out of his car just... Dude, it's all just cars!
They're all just chasing each other in cars!
That was this Fortnite season at the very, very beginning.
Cause, like, there was, like, nothing to counter them.
It was ridiculous.
Oh, my god!
Oh, they got EMP'd!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god!
It's a non-car fight!
One guy EMP'd their car!
Fuck that car in particular!
This is very...
Okay, I feel like they should ban cars.
This is...
Like, what the fuck am I watching right now?
It's literally just... Sorry guys, I tabbed out.
So that's why there's no sound.
I'm literally watching car fights.
Like, we got fucked just cause we didn't have a car.
We're now playing Twisted Metal.
This is literally Twisted Metal right now.
Oh, my god!
Those poor fools!
They're just hiding in there!
They're just hiding in the house!
Fools!
That was yesterday!
This meta is car meta!
Honestly, seeing how, like, vehicle heavy it is, I'm gonna definitely run my anti-car, like, loadout.
Cause I think this is all people are gonna do is just drive around and stuff.
Yeah.
Bro, what happened to the players that were in that house?
Wait, did they die already?
I don't know, they just disappeared.
They're just chilling here.
They're like parked here.
They just parked here cause they don't have to move.
Wait, I think we do...
Honestly, I think this is car meta.
There's no way we can play this without cars.
There's like four fucking medallions all around them.
They're making a Venn diagram on the map.
Let me see the next rules.
I think the next game... It's a safe zone.
...is...
So, there's definitely...
Oh, so it's a safe zone.
That's what it is, yeah.
Yeah, so nobody's gonna shoot us.
Okay, well...
Bro, they're playing hide and seek with cars.
One car is just trying to hide behind buildings.
They're playing hide and seek behind a car.
Oh my god, if we were still alive it'd be so much fun to use the magneto gloves on all these.
Oh my god.
I love it.
If we, like, hit at the right moment and just come out with all these cars... Yeah, cars are... I think cars are allowed on all games, right?
I think so, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going through all the rules and...
I'm pretty sure... Yeah, it's like vehicles all games.
Bro, oh my god.
Oh, wait, they killed...
Oh, it's bunker!
Oh my god!
They're breaking the bunker!
Yeah, it's like pointless to even have bunkers.
I mean, like, you can, but like...
Yeah, he just builds... he just runs over.
He ramps the fucking bunkers.
So, basically all you have to do is you gotta have a repair tool.
Yeah.
And then you can just keep on killing the vehicles.
Oh!
I just saw this man run him over.
How is there still 31 people alive?
This is... Oh, thank fucking god.
Okay.
Insane.
Okay, there's way too many people alive.
Like, how many cars are there?
Like, there's actually way too many people alive.
Wait, where's the other?
Oh, the other one's here.
Oh, they... he left him to die.
Oh, they're like...
Oh, never mind, they're dead.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, okay, so this condom has been... Oh, no, never mind, their teammate literally... Yeah, no, their teammate literally died, no.
Their teammate is...
is the... Oh, shit, he got fucking... Oh, my god!
Did he just stole his car?
Wait, what?
Oh, he just got it.
Wait, did he oink it?
He might oink it.
Wait, why is there three people?
Why is there three people in the car?
Why is there...
Wait, why is there... Why is there...
You see three people in the car, right?
Yeah.
Why is there...
Wait, what?
You can literally get into an enemy's vehicle and just ride with them.
It's so silly.
It's so fucking silly.
Wait, were they oinking together?
What?
How?
Are they...
Is this an alliance?
Are they... Who did the bullshit?
Why is there four people in this car?
Why there's four people in this car?
I don't understand.
This is actually...
This is ridiculous.
I'm very familiar with zero bill tournaments.
This is actually so ridiculous.
It is so silly.
This is like mutual destruction because all four of them they're not shooting at each other.
They just...
I don't understand.
It's wild because they get to basically just work with each other and there's no penalty because they basically just get to keep living.
Yeah.
It's so... It's so...
It's so random.
Like, is it because he saw they were also condom men?
So they're like condom men stick together.
Condoms stick together.
Like, I don't...
Condoms versus everyone.
I don't understand why they did it.
How come the other car people shot him but that car didn't?
I love...
I love hearing your reactions to all these things.
It is so fucking valid.
I don't understand.
It is so valid.
Oh, thank fucking god.
Oh, they're like...
They're like one HP?
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
This is insane.
Oh my god.
I'm just happy that team didn't win.
I prefer no build, but what the fuck?
No build, guys.
What the fuck is this?
It's literally no build.
That's what I'm saying.
That is what I'm saying.
Holy shit.
This guy's literally one HP.
Oh my god.
No!
Why is it called no build when there's all these?
Don't let him win!
No!
Listen!
A condom man win!
No!
This is unfair.
We should report them.
Wait, I don't even know who eliminated me.
I'm gonna...
Teaming up with enemies.
I saw him team up!
I saw him!
He teamed!
Oh my god.
He 100% teamed!
I...
We all saw
him!
No, you're not!
No, you're on it!
You're on it.
We literally all saw him team, guys.
We have video proof.
He jumped into the car and nobody...
Nobody did anything.
The condom people made a made a union.
And they said together...
Together we can win against everyone that doesn't use condoms.
That's so fucked up.
Alright.
Oh, do you have alien...
Do you have an alien skin?
I do.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you have an alien one too?
No, no.
I have Dead Space.
Oh, you have Dead Space?
Oh wait, you have Isaac Clarke?
Yeah, I have Isaac.
It can be an alien.
Yes!
Okay, I'm gonna be a...
I'm gonna be a xenomorph.
Yeah, that's perfect.
I knew that I can be like this gross-ass thing.
Oh god, no.
No, absolutely not.
Oh, you're gonna be this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's perfect.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna put on a... I'm gonna wear a pink backpack.
Wait, no.
Actually... I think I have like Isaac's stuff.
I have the health thing.
Yeah, the life thing.
Oh, yeah, I do.
I do.
I have his like... his shit.
I have the health thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
I'm full of Isaac.
Oh, are you using the...
Is there two?
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got the cutter.
Okay, cool, cool.
I got the cutter on too.
We good.
Come on, Isaac.
We're gonna work it.
We're gonna work it out.
Okay, it looks fucking ridiculous with the xenomorph.
I don't remember if it's in Dead Space.
Wait, what?
Wait, what is this one?
That's the... That just got in the store.
What the fuck?
Fagada.
Just how I remembered Dead Space.
Yeah, I remember when Isaac fought this... the xenomorph.
Yeah, yeah.
In Dead Space 3.
Yeah, and he went pew, pew.
That's how he did it.
Literally like that.
Literally.
He saw the xenomorph, pew, pew.
Yeah.
And then the xenomorph was like, Yo, let's take a selfie!
Yo!
Oh, yeah, I remember when the xenomorph was like, yo, selfie time?
Yeah, yeah, selfie time.
And then Isaac Opa Ganon styled on him.
It's canon!
It is canon.
It's literally canon.
Wait, when does he do...
Dead Space 5?
Yeah, yeah, it's in Dead Space 5.
It's in the newest Dead Space, guys.
You guys don't know because... and then he was like, only Goku can save us.
Wait, did you...
Oh, wait, we don't have a code yet.
No, no, no, yeah.
I'm waiting for it.
Wait, do we get it?
Oh, they just... no, no, no, no.
They didn't.
Oh my god.
We got this.
We got this, guys.
Easy.
Alright, so since we're in safe zone...
Wait, where are we landing?
Um, we're landing at Grim Gate.
Okay.
From where our server is spawned at.
Okay, you just have to ping it for me.
Yay, I'll do the pingy ping thing.
Yeah, and then we gotta get a car.
After everything we just saw, we definitely need a car.
We are gonna get a vehicle.
And then if we...
if our car dies, we gotta steal... we gotta, like, hop in somebody's house.
Oh, wait, wait.
The vehicles were so bad last game that they put...
they put a poll in the Discord about banning cars.
Wait, they put a poll on whether or not to ban the cars?
Wait, where's the poll?
It's in all chats.
Ban cars?
No.
Cause I wanna...
No!
Okay, we need to get our own car.
Let's get a car.
I never got a chance to be in a car.
I should be in a car.
I should have...
have one free car game.
Gaining one car game.
Just me, though.
Uh, new rule?
Doki is the only one that gets a car.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, I'll show you guys what I wrote.
Oh, I love how you already got a reaction.
Yeah, somebody was like, yes.
I had three people that agreed with me.
Thank god.
Okay.
My god.
What the fuck is FNCS?
That's a Fortnite competitive.
Oh, is it like competitive?
Oh.
Yeah, it's all the competitive players, yeah.
Oh, so right after this they have like a Fortnite tournament.
Oh, they're doing FNCS after.
Yeah.
So some people were like we should have builds, because we're doing... Okay.
Okay guys, this is what I wrote and then people agreed with me.
I love that everyone's just like, yes, you don't get a car.
Nobody definitely gets a car.
Just me though.
And then the emo, like the emo is named Yes.
So people agreed with me.
It's just, it's just, it's just nodding.
It's a nodding emo.
What if they literally just give you the vehicle?
Remove cars from the rest of the... and then I voted no.
I voted no.
Because I wanted...
I'm voting no for you.
Because I never got a chance.
What if only I get the car though?
As the team that's last place.
That should be my crutch.
Wait, what?
No, that's a joke.
I got the very, very end of that.
I was like, wait.
No, Sean, someone said that.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
Nobody.
32 people voted yes to banning cars.
That's not fair.
That was me.
I voted for us.
Dang.
Everyone really do.
You should just let me have the car.
No, I want the vehicle.
Make it fair.
I...
Come on.
What?
Me having a special...
Me having a special privilege makes it fair.
Is this called a Doki roll?
Yeah, it would be so funny.
They don't know what content is.
I love how.
Like, even though I, I'm not a fan of like vehicle chaos.
I actually don't mind it in a dumb tournament like this.
I'm totally open for it.
Yeah, everybody wins anyway.
Yeah, everyone's gonna win.
Everybody's gonna have money.
It'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
No, I need to win 20 more dollars.
Oh wait, that's true.
Is it like the next placement is just like 20 or 50 more dollars or something?
Wait, for game two, no special rules restrictions.
Cars are not allowed for the rest of the games.
No!
This is not fair.
This should be illegal.
I wonder like if the medallions are still gonna be a thing.
I think the medallions aren't allowed on like two of the matches?
This is rigged.
This is rigged against me.
I feel it.
Oh, they literally just edited the rules too.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, so that's... Okay, so game two is just gonna be like...
What?
What are they doing for game two then?
Wait, what?
Wait, isn't game two mostly cars?
Yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, they turned off the safety zone?
Wait, they turned off the safe zone?
Wait, what?
Uh...
I like how all they did was ask about vehicles.
And then they like removed all the rules.
I'm so confused.
This has been the most confus...
Actually, no, this has not been the most confusing Twitch Rivals I've had.
I've had more confusing ones.
I was about to say no.
No, I meant...
There's Apex Rivals.
Apex Rivals is a whole different beast.
I've had more confusing ones.
I can't believe it.
These rules are against me.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna find out who that guy was, who that car was, and report him again.
All in favor of reporting.
He did this to me.
I was so...
I was gonna look for...
I was so looking forward to having a car.
You know what?
Everything was chill.
And then you saw them, Tina, and you're like, what?
It
would've been so fun!
Can you imagine if like we actually like...
played a way where we could just...
get into an enemy's vehicle?
Yeah!
It would've been so fun!
They're ruining my fun!
I was so excited.
I'm actually sad.
I was so fucking excited too.
I was like, oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking get into somebody's car after what I saw.
Oh, big sadge.
Big sadge.
This is a conspiracy.
They did this purposely against me.
They knew I was so happy.
They knew I was gonna be so happy having a car.
And?
They're like, Doki, happiness?
Never!
We're gonna get rid of everything she loves about Fortnite.
You and I are literally both the same.
I'm just like, just make the game crazy.
Literally, add in all the mythics.
Like...
Let everyone go wild with it.
It's not...
I...
Isn't like FNCS...
You win more money in FNCS than you do Twitch Rivals.
Oh, you definitely do.
Yeah.
Why are you so serious here?
Because that's how Fortnite players are.
They're like, I need to take every mode seriously.
It's a game for children.
This game was originally made for children.
Like...
A fucking 14-year-old kid won a Fortnite championship.
I was literally just telling my chat, I was like...
This game is the best when it's just chaotic.
And then it gets turned into condom skin wearing simulator.
This game was literally originally made for kids.
Why are they like this?
Why are they like...
Oh, yeah.
You crap.
You fucking...
We're like, everyone's going to know who we are at this point.
But...
Yeah.
We're like, they're the only one with actual skins.
I should change my stream title to the only team with skins.
All right.
Where are we going?
We're lighting here.
The Grim Gate.
Oh, the one with the speedy.
Yeah.
It's where all the Baja Blast is.
The Baja Blast.
Yeah.
We're going to get Baja Blast and it's going to be with us all game.
Until we use it.
Or if the zone pulls here, which is very possible.
All right.
Drop now.
Nice.
Whee!
Are you using the Wacking Playbill too, man?
Yeah.
Like I said, I don't have any like cool gliders or...
No.
That one's amazing.
I love that one.
That's like...
That's my only cool one.
All the other ones are boring.
All right.
Are we going to pass it?
There's no way.
We had drops.
We called it out.
I think we're getting...
Wait.
Why is there one person here?
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Yeah.
They're like landing right there.
They're landing with us.
I see it.
All right.
Well, let's get looted and then we're going to have to fight them.
My God.
Fucking...
They're condom men.
They're condom men though.
I'm scared.
Oh, it's the God dang condom men.
All right.
Well, I got a shotgun.
I got a Thunder Burst.
I got a shotgun too.
There's shields here.
Okay.
I need that.
Are you going to hit them together?
All right.
I'm here.
Okay.
Let's hit these.
I'm going to hit the ground so that way it gets both of us.
And then I'm going to get the other one here.
Then we'll get the last one here.
All right.
Perfect.
Nice.
Okay.
Cool.
So we got that.
And then there's bubbles here as well.
All right.
So...
I'm scared.
They're probably going to be playing on height.
We have to worry about them.
Oh my...
And you should take the big shield.
Oh, no, no.
You take it.
Take it.
Okay.
I'll just drink it now.
I'm just going to watch for them.
I don't know where they are.
That's what scares me.
Same.
There's probably one on top of the roof.
I'm just going to be on the lookout for.
Here, let's touch the Baja Blast if we haven't touched it.
We haven't touched it yet?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We touched the Baja Blast.
We got the Baja Blast.
And then I'm going to nitrous.
That way we can get the other heals here.
Actually, wait.
We can just probably...
No.
That's the NPC.
Did they remove the safe zone?
Yeah.
They removed it.
Okay.
I think it's just everyone playing like normal right now.
What?
Oh my...
Wait.
They have these in?
What the fuck?
What is that?
Oh, isn't that the really overpowered shit?
Just use it.
Use it.
Use it real quick.
They're above us.
Wait.
Use it.
I don't know how to do...
It's all good.
Okay.
They're definitely over here though.
What do I do?
I think you just summon a thing.
Like a...
Right now?
A ship.
Yeah.
Just do it.
Do towards them here.
This way?
Yeah.
Boom!
Goodbye.
Did we do it?
Yeah, you did.
Did we?
Yeah.
They're above us right now.
They're above us.
Okay.
Want to do it again?
All right.
I don't have one.
Are you going to wake up on us, I think?
That was literally the only thing I had.
Oh, really?
Oh, it's only a one use.
Yeah.
There's only one use.
They're below.
They're right below here.
They're right here.
All right.
138 on one.
Oh.
Here?
109 on another.
They backed off.
Okay.
I'm messing them up.
They're pretty scared.
Well, that's good.
That's good.
Okay.
I'm going to fully heal this.
I'm going to get some Baja Blast, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get some Baja Blast.
All right.
I got some Nitro still.
I'm trying to see where these guys are.
Oh, that's scary.
We can go to the top of the roof here.
Let's go up.
Okay.
Oh, I see them.
They are all the way out here.
Yep.
They're back here.
Careful.
I see them.
Oh.
Did they break this?
Oh, okay.
I'm getting on the rooftop.
They're just jumping.
I'm going to get an angle.
They're trying to break my pillar.
Oh, I see.
I see them.
Yeah.
They're right here.
Looking.
I'm trying to play angles where we don't get shot in the back.
That's fucked up.
They won't let me drive a car, but I can...
Whoa!
I got shot in the side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come inside.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I don't know where I got shot.
I cracked this one.
126 on them.
Where is he?
Knocked him.
Nice.
Can you thirst him?
Or no?
Yeah.
I'm thirsting him.
Yep.
Thirsted him.
Nice.
We got a kill.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Get shit on.
My bodyguard did it.
Yeah.
We're going to cap your fucking body.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, fucker.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
They were trying to be all sneaky and stuff.
That was actually the same team.
Yeah.
What's the Iron Warrior?
Is the Iron Warrior better than the laser?
Oh.
Is people flying?
Flying over here?
Careful.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Go inside.
I'm trying to.
Whoa.
I'm trying to get an angle.
Trying to get an angle.
They're chasing, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, they got me.
They got me.
Is that a new team?
It's a new team.
Oh, please.
Run.
It's the condom.
Just leave me.
It's the condoms.
I'm going.
Just leave.
I never existed.
I'm going.
Just keep running.
No.
Just leave.
I'm living.
Oh my God.
Just keep living.
Are they still there?
I think so.
Oh my God.
It sucks because I have no other mobility right now.
Yeah.
Except for...
Oh no.
I'm probably dead.
I think so.
I think so too.
Oh my God.
See, you have to climb that.
It's hurting me right now.
I know, right?
See.
Oh my God.
I'm alive somehow.
Never stop running.
I'm going to keep going.
I'm going to go.
Just keep going.
Wait.
Oh yeah.
They know you.
He will never know.
There'll never know.
Do you have...
You got bandages.
Yup.
I'm going to chill for a sec and wait to see if they fall out all the way.
I don't think they did.
I'm proud of us.
We got to kill.
Yeah, we got to kill.
We got to fucking kill.
We did it.
You got the kill.
No, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Guys, I was a good bait.
I'm terrified.
I feel like they're gonna be on the outskirts here.
I feel like it too.
It's the condom people.
I can always...
I'm so annoyed that they have gloves.
I never get gloves.
Yeah, how do they get the gloves?
It's just RNG because there's no NPCs or anything.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't believe they, like, contested us.
I know, right?
Like, what?
Who are they?
Wait, what was the guy that we killed?
I think it was a name that started with an X, I think.
I'm gonna find you.
They're here.
There's someone here.
Did they hear that when you swapped guns?
They do, but I'm gonna go over here.
Oh my god, game.
Okay, we're good.
But what if they destroy your house?
I could die.
Oh, the medallion.
The medallion people, they're trying to find you.
Oh my god.
They'll never search here, right?
I don't know.
It's not fair.
They'll never search here.
There's two.
There's two of them.
I think they're trying to find each other.
Oh, wait.
Is there a vending machine here?
Oh, there's no vending machine.
I was gonna say, it can, like, use EMPs to...
get gold?
And then I can, like, full heal.
There's also a bunch of cactuses around here too I can use to heal.
Oh, they're leaving.
They're leaving.
Yeah, I think they're converging.
Are they trying to chase each other?
I think they are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're chasing each other.
Wait, I might be able to get your card.
I'm serious.
88 seconds?
Yeah.
I can actually go back.
Well, as long as these guys don't linger.
I don't think they are, right?
They're...
I don't know what they're doing.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
This is good.
Wait, what happened?
Oh, they're gone.
They're gone.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's either all or nothing.
Like...
I'm gonna try.
70 seconds.
Oh.
They're fighting?
Wait, the shotgun?
Okay.
They knocked somebody.
Yeah, they fenced someone.
My tail is so long.
I think they can see your tail.
They're gonna see your tail.
Oh, that's an NPC.
It's a condom skin.
We're good.
Oh, I don't think he can get me anymore.
No, I'm going.
I'm going.
No, no.
There's no way.
That's 45 seconds.
I'm going.
There's no way.
You don't have heals.
No, I got two bandages.
There's no way.
You're crazy.
We're doing this.
You're gonna die in storm.
That's even worse.
No.
We're good.
27 seconds.
You're gonna die in storm, Doryu.
Like, 100.
No, no, no.
We can do it.
Are you sure?
Yup.
Okay.
60 seconds.
I'm going.
We're doing this.
9.
8.
7.
I got you.
We're good.
Okay.
But how are you gonna live?
That's a good question.
I don't know.
Okay.
I literally said this is not a good idea because I don't think you're gonna live in the storm.
No.
The nice thing is there's a bunch of...
There's a bunch of cactuses I can heal on.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, my God.
There's pigs here.
There's pigs.
Yes.
We got some bats.
We got shield bats.
Oh.
Just leave.
I don't think I need the EMPs.
I'm just gonna probably swap these.
Where's the cactuses?
Okay.
Let's grab that.
And then let's do this.
Oh.
I was hoping for a nitro.
Dang.
Okay.
All good.
Gonna grab those.
Oh, my God.
Doryu is stressing me out right now.
Okay.
You know what?
No.
Let's grab this.
Let's do that.
You're stressing me out right now.
Look at that.
Look at that right there.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Let's go.
I was like, I'm seeing those numbers go down.
I think it should be okay for a little bit.
He looks so carefree while in the storm.
I'm just like, oh.
Okay.
If you say so.
I want nitro.
Guys.
Doryu needs somebody to gift him Discord Nitro, guys.
Can he get to this?
I need Discord Nitro.
Guys.
Any gifters in chat?
I wonder if I should revive you?
How far?
I mean, it's not that far.
It's pretty far.
Okay.
Maybe it is.
In the next zone?
Yeah.
Well, actually, we'll find on the next zone.
Do you have enough heals?
I'm gonna talk to this guy.
He might give me a med kit.
Oh, wait.
Gold?
And then...
Med kit?
No!
That's not med kit!
That's a shield cell.
Frick.
Okay.
I think you gotta go to zone at this point or find a cactus.
There may be a cactus on my right that might not be taken.
I was really hoping there'd be a vending machine here.
Oh.
Yes.
Oh, thank God.
And there's a...
There's a...
There's a chest, too.
I think I might...
Oh, do I revive you?
I think I'm gonna try reviving you here.
There's an archer.
There's a cactus.
Nice.
We're living this.
Oh, you're still alive.
You're alive.
You're still alive.
I feel the life in you.
How has only...
There's...
Oh, my God.
There's so many people still alive.
Yeah.
That's like my only worry is that there's gonna be teams on the outskirts here, like...
I'm just kinda chilling out here.
Oh, my God.
There's definitely gonna be a team up there.
Yeah.
I'm gonna drop.
Oh, my God.
I'm not seeing this whole area yet.
Oh, it's the Pirates of the Caribbean area.
Yeah.
They literally just added it.
That's sick.
That's how we got our ghost ship.
I wish the ghost ship was...
I guess it was too broken for it to be like...
Do I rev you?
Do it.
It'll be so funny.
I wanna make sure...
Is there a team on the island?
There's no one up there.
It'll be so funny.
Do it.
You know what?
I'm doing it.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
Bring back our team.
Isaac.
Fuck it.
Bring him back.
Oh, wait.
This one is faster.
Oh, this one?
Yeah.
The reboot seems a lot faster than usual.
Okay.
We're gonna have a team definitely like waiting for us on the outside.
But I have bubbles ready.
I know.
Shenron's here.
And then there's shields here.
And then we have a bunch of cactus we can hit too.
Nice.
All right.
Here.
I'm gonna split these with you.
And I'm gonna drop you one of these.
Nice.
I'm gonna pop that.
I'm popping it.
That's right.
Do you want a sniper rifle?
Do you want a long range?
I can find a gun.
There's some guns.
It's all right.
Okay.
Here.
Let's hit this.
Yay.
I'm back.
Then let's start going.
What's that sound?
Those are teams rotating.
Oh, there's a gun right here.
Shotgun?
No.
It's...
That's fine.
I don't want to risk it.
Here.
Let me give you my gun then.
Because I already have a really good gun.
So.
Okay.
I'll give you this.
I'm gonna...
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Somebody's gonna...
Alright.
Smoke those dudes.
Another team is gonna kill me to get that gun.
Are you sure?
I don't know.
Yes.
I'm sure.
I don't know if I should have this gun right now.
I believe...
I don't know.
Okay.
Just make sure you have the Gibby dome ready for if we have any teams that try to like rotate on us.
Yeah.
Of course.
It's a zone all the way up there.
Wait.
What?
You have one more.
Yeah.
This game is so buggy.
I didn't even like burn one.
But it like used it.
I was totally thinking about claiming that drop spot all the way up here.
Because I was like what if a zone goes up there and there's only a zone up there right now?
Let's go through here, Toki.
Let's go through here.
All right.
I'm right behind you.
Okay.
I have the dome ready.
All right.
I'm holding the dome too.
Wouldn't it be funny if we just took the car for like one second?
Like how would they know?
How would they know?
Okay.
Let's go down here.
How would they know?
It could be risky, but fuck it.
Oh, there's a big here.
You can hold on to that.
And then we can hit these.
And then let's hit this one here.
And then we're going to have to start moving through the tunnel.
All right.
Okay.
Shotgun here.
Oh, nice.
There's an AR here.
You can have this gun back then.
You sure?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm 100% sure.
Let's start shooting.
All right.
Let's go.
And then...
Oh, I'm actually carrying the med kits.
Yeah.
I'm going to carry those for us.
Oh, there's a magneto thing.
Oh, shit.
I'll grab it.
Okay.
Oh, there's a deagle here.
Oh, we have nitrous.
We have nitrous.
Here, come next to me.
Yeah.
Here, here.
I'm going to pop this.
You want to hold the med kit?
Yeah.
Hold the med kit.
I dropped the magneto.
You want it?
That's fine.
Team up here.
Oh, there's a ghost ship.
I'm going to grab that actually.
Wait.
Let's get this guy.
They're right here.
Cracked.
I'm going to chase.
Oh, you're so far.
Knocked him.
Nice.
I'm right behind you.
I have a ghost ship.
Oh, they have gloves.
Yo.
Oh, my God.
Get it.
Grab it.
You don't want it?
No, no, no.
You should have it.
I have magneto.
Oh, I can't grab it.
It's like stuck there.
Wait.
It fell down.
It's right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to drop nitro.
I'm dropping a nitro.
And then I'm going to try to...
I need heals.
I don't have heals.
No, no, no, no, no.
I thought you took it.
No, no.
I dropped it for you.
Okay.
Whoop.
All right.
That's awkward.
Oh, we got to go.
We got to go.
Oh, no.
I fucked up.
Okay.
I'm dead.
I'm dead to the zone.
I can pop a med kit and I can grab you.
Okay.
Just keep running up.
Keep running up.
I'm crawling.
I'm going to come back for you.
There's too many stuff to carry.
I was like, what do I get?
I'm confused.
I got overwhelmed.
I got you.
You're good.
You raised me up.
No one's going to see us.
Oh, my God.
There's a team there.
You raised me up.
I got this.
Oh, no.
I'm dead.
Liv.
Target is in my cushion.
Oh, no.
Liv.
No.
My green won because I wanted the ghost ship.
I threw it because I wanted the ghost ship.
I saw it.
It's okay.
No.
At least we got two kills though.
We got two kills.
Oh, thank God.
That is all good.
Thank God.
I can't believe it.
I got so greedy.
Because I was like, oh shit.
Wait.
Why is replays all the way out here?
He got knocked by zone.
Yeah.
Why were they all the way out here?
Why did they choose to push us?
Why were they?
Yeah.
Why did they choose to push us?
They could have literally just started rotating.
That was a smart thing to do.
I wanted to be a pirate.
That's all I want.
Wait.
They died to zone.
Because we had zero heals.
Yeah.
They died to zone.
They hoped we had heals and they died to fucking...
Oh, my God.
We're fucking losers.
They actually thought we had heals for the farm off of...
That's right.
We had no heals.
We also...
Oh, my God.
The worst gamble.
Oh, I had the ghost ship.
That's it.
They're like, oh, this guy definitely has heals.
Jokes on you, sucker.
I got a ghost ship.
The guy you killed was Bucky?
The same guy Doki was calling out for dying five times at one game?
That's funny.
Oh, really?
Oh, that's...
Yeah.
The ones who challenged us.
Oh, my God.
It's amazing.
Double punish.
Yeah.
I was thinking 50 steps ahead by not picking up that med kit.
By not picking up that med kit, they didn't get any heals.
Wait.
Did we kill both of them because of it?
Yeah.
They both died to storm.
They both died to...
All right.
So deserved.
No, Bucky.
I can't believe it.
They both died to storm.
That was actually so gigabrain about everything you literally did there.
Yeah.
I purposely did not pick up a med kit because I wanted those two to die to zone.
My indirect kills.
I might have not got a kill by shooting my gun, but I got my kills by mental damage.
That's my teammate.
Emotional damage.
At least I died by gunshot.
Dying by zone because of lack of heals is so fucking embarrassing.
Chat will never let them live that down because of it.
Chat's like, no, no, no.
It was actually all part of the plan.
If you die to someone shooting at you, that you're as respectable.
But you dying to zone was a choice that you made willingly.
Right.
And Chat will heavily bully you for that shit.
That's why I said that.
Technically, I didn't die to zone.
I died to a guy that shot me.
I died to me failing you as a werewolf bodyguard.
I technically didn't die to zone.
I got finished out inside.
I got finished inside the spot.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're good.
Everything was fine.
Yeah.
It was all according to plan.
I can't believe nobody's dying in this game though.
I wonder if the team that was challenging us at the very beginning.
I wonder if they all died way earlier.
Because we still got like 17th place.
So I'm just like wondering.
Wait, what the fuck?
You're right.
Yeah.
So like nobody died.
That's what I'm like thinking.
I was like, holy shit.
Nobody died.
Yeah.
That's actually crazy.
You know what though?
How is people alive still?
We got two kills this game.
Yeah.
We got two kills.
And then last game we got one kill, right?
Yeah.
We got one kill, yeah.
So we got three points from that.
Let's go.
We're not dead last.
Okay.
I don't know about that.
Because I feel like there's a lot of them.
A lot of the other weaker teams, like the non-Fortnite players.
They're like...
They have...
They just like stay in zone.
Yeah.
I saw like their points were mostly just from...
Oh my God.
The positioning.
Yeah.
Displacement.
It's like...
It's kind of similar to Apex where it's like priority on surviving.
Yeah.
And then kill points are just like a little like add up or whatever.
Extra.
Yeah.
Woo.
Thank you for the radar.
Welcome in.
Thank you shape-shifting trap for the two months.
Oh my God.
That's the Magneto gloves.
Whoa.
Someone's using Magneto gloves?
Yeah.
Up the hill.
The Javes team.
They were using Magneto gloves?
Yeah.
Magneto gloves to like throw it at people downstairs.
Oh.
What?
Yeah.
That thing's like insane for like builds.
I literally saw them like...
He has fists and Magneto gloves?
Hell yeah.
This is the loadout I usually have to run.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
It literally owns like people on like any surface.
How is like weapon bans not banning fists or...
Like I don't think any of the gloves are banned.
Yeah.
No.
They're all in.
Which I think...
I think it's like...
Is this sponsored by Disney?
Is this like...
Like...
I don't understand.
They ban regular guns but still...
How...
How the Disney gloves are not banned.
Like I don't understand.
Why are the Disney gloves still in here?
Like...
Oh my God.
Also the crazy thing about the gloves is they go through the shield bubble too.
Are we trying to advertise Disney right now?
They don't need more advertising.
Oh my God.
Disney overlords wanted in.
Use the gloves!
There you go!
Is State Farm owned by Disney?
Is that it?
Did they get bought by Disney today?
Wait!
The universe is coming together!
Everything is owned by Disney!
Probably.
It goes deep.
My soul is owned by Disney.
I'm a Lion King nerd.
Oh!
The magneto gloves people won.
Nice.
Yeah!
No condom skin!
Thank God!
Dang.
I'm just gonna run that loadout.
Alright, what are we doing next?
Alright, I have... What would go well with this skin?
I don't know.
Oh, with that skin?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a Marvel skin.
Oh no, it's like totally opposite.
You said fake fan!
You said Marvel!
I'm gonna be Marvel?
I can't believe it!
Wait, what's a Marv... I mean, do you have a Marvel equivalent?
I have so many Marv... I have no DC skins.
But do you have like a Marvel equivalent to...
Um...
To... To...
The Batman who laughs.
I can be Thanos.
He's like a villain.
A Thanos... Okay.
You know what?
Yeah, let's get Thanos.
Let's get the biggest hitbox in here.
You know what?
Let's do it.
I'm gonna be Thanos.
Oh, I do have Beast Boy.
I lied.
I have Beast Boy.
That Batman sucks.
Fuck you guys!
He is the best Batman!
He's my favorite Batman!
Fuck you guys!
Which one?
The Batman who laughs?
Yeah, the Batman who laughs.
People are like roasting my Batman.
Isn't there like a really, really dark variant?
Oh, yeah.
It's like extra dark.
Yeah, he's like... He got bitten by the Joker.
It's like, you know how you get fisted by a wolf and you turn into a werewolf?
Yeah, yeah.
He got...
He gets fisted by a Joker?
That's what the fanfics wants you to...
Wait, do you have Loki?
I do have Loki.
Wait, no, no, no.
I don't have Loki.
Oh, Loki would have worked.
Yeah.
Wait, I need Thanos.
Do Thanos.
Okay, I'm gonna be Thanos.
Ironically, you're gonna run Thanos.
Wait, what big X are you using?
What are you gonna use?
Oh, I'm using the pom-poms because I want to cheer you on.
Let's go.
Okay.
I can use... I have an inflatable pool noodle.
A balloon.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That'll work.
Okay, I'm gonna do that one.
Okay, I have a small hitbox and you have the biggest hitbox.
This will work.
This is gonna work.
Wait, what's your back bling?
My back bling is like golf shit.
Wait, golf shit?
My back bling, cat, uh, ride a cat.
Okay, I can run...
Wait, what is some, like, golf shit I can run?
I can use, like...
It's the perfect balance.
Dang, what do I... Chat, what do I use?
I need a spiky backpack or something.
Pew, pew.
Pew.
I mean, I could use that one.
Oh, no, here I have the anarchy backpack.
The anarchy backpack?
What's that?
Yeah, it, uh... Hold on.
Let me turn around real quick.
Yay!
What the f- Oh, it has, like, spikes on the backpack!
It has, like, spikes all over itself.
Yeah!
Uh...
Come on, guys.
We're the perfect team.
Oh, I could... I can't believe I didn't do the golf dance with the golf batman.
The dance that matters the most.
Oh, shit.
You're actually them.
I'm actually them.
The best batman.
Oh, my God.
That's so fucking cursed with Thanos.
Oh, shit.
You're actually them.
That's so...
That's so bad with Thanos.
Holy shit.
Alright, what's the... what's the rule three?
The game for game number three.
What's the rules?
Oh, the rules are...
Um... let's see.
Because I know there's hotspot, right?
It's literally the same for game three.
Wait, what?
Yeah, literally the same, yeah.
Then game four is when it changes.
Wait, so they actually...
They actually removed save zones.
Yeah, they basically got rid of the save zones.
Why?
I think because, like, people were saying, like, oh, we want the games to go longer or faster.
Oh, because of the Fortnite thing, yeah.
But it's, like, counterintuitive.
It's counterintuitive, though, because everyone still lives until end zone.
Yeah.
So...
It's for us.
The save zone's for us.
We're just little people.
Yeah.
We're the little people.
Oh.
Fortnite...
You guys have, like, 100 million tournaments.
Come on.
This is our one tournament.
The one tournament we're supposed to be in for fun.
It's so regular Fortnite rules.
Come on.
You guys literally have a tournament right after this tournament.
Like, you...
Like, they're like, no, no, we have to warm up for our next tournament with more money on it.
Like, what the fuck?
Like...
We actually have another tournament right after this tournament.
Wait.
What?
What are they...
Is there something they tagged us all in?
On chat?
Huh?
Oh, no.
We're okay.
No.
The code's out.
We have, like, a thing on there.
Yeah.
We got the code.
All right.
I'm ready to go.
Okay.
So, literally, same rules.
Same rules, by the way.
We're just little guys.
We're just little guys trying to make it in this cruel Fortnite world.
You know what's funny?
Is I think I killed the other player that was...
That was on the team.
Yeah.
That had two more points than us yesterday.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
That's when we were rotating near the big...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The big firing.
Wait.
Are they still gonna contest us?
They might.
Let me actually see the...
I wanna see the draw spots real quick.
Yeah.
Like, why are they contesting us?
We claimed that.
They probably...
It's probably because they saw who we were.
And they're like, oh, they're easily killable.
Yeah.
But little did they know...
Right, bitch.
I have a bodyguard.
I might be easily killable, but I have a bodyguard.
They don't know.
Yeah.
Wait.
They're literally...
They decided to chow us.
Wait.
They actually decided to, like, just...
Yeah.
They added their names on top of us.
Oh.
Yeah.
We already had it.
But they're like...
We're the only team getting contested, by the way.
Wait.
What?
Out of everywhere on the map.
Yeah.
Wait.
But, like...
Like, what do you mean?
Did they, like, just add it there...
They dropped it on top of you, guys?
Yeah.
They just...
They literally threw it at us.
They just threw their box on top of us, and then they added their name there.
I don't see...
Wait.
I don't see their name.
Where is it?
Wait.
Really?
I clicked the latest one.
Oh.
I mean, that's fine.
I will happily keep killing them.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is wrong with...
Wait.
You're right.
Yeah.
No, it's J3 in a plunge.
Are you...
Wait.
Who's that?
It's the Overwatch players.
Oh, it's the Overwatch players.
Get shit on.
They're Overwatch players.
Oh, my God.
You got fucking shit on you.
You got, like, killed by one guy that doesn't even play Overwatch.
Fucking...
He's not...
Dory has not fucking been in Overwatch World Cup or anything, but he fucking shit on you, too.
You guys are professional gamers?
Like...
My favorite thing about the fight was that they both peeked me.
Yeah.
And they missed their giggle shots.
And I was like...
I was like, what?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That's funny.
I can't believe that was them.
I can't believe that was J3 in a plunge.
Oh, my God.
That is hilarious.
All right, chat.
Time to challenge some Overwatch players.
I might be shit, but I have a player that's better than both of you.
Like...
Let's fucking go.
Guys, it's okay to shit talk to them, because they purposely contested us.
Yeah.
They literally had...
We literally had to drop before them.
Yeah.
They literally could drop anywhere.
Like...
They could have...
There's, like, so many places they could drop at, but they decided to contest us.
Like...
I wonder what the dialogue was.
They're probably like, oh, yeah.
That's just...
Yeah.
They're last place.
We can...
They're VTubers.
Yeah.
We can kill them.
They're last place.
They can...
We can handle it.
They totally never killed Apex pros or anything like that.
Wait.
We're 15?
Let's fucking go.
Wait.
Where's J3 and Reply?
I don't even know.
No.
Where are these guys?
Let's fucking go.
Oh, yeah.
Thanks for giving us a point to be 15th place.
Fuck, yeah.
I'm proud of us.
Me too.
We synergized.
I'm proud of us, too.
Oh, Jay's in, like, 18th?
Damn.
Oh, my God.
They're 19th.
And Holynia's in, like, middle of formation.
Land on us, again!
Give us another point!
Land on us again!
I'm walking down.
I'm down, please do.
We are hungry.
We're hungry.
They got 19th place in that game.
Oh, my...
Oh, dude!
They did die early!
Yeah.
They died so early that night.
I think they died when I was hiding?
Yeah.
Do you remember how, like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
...I saw one of the condoms or whatever?
I'm pretty sure that was them.
Wait, did you?
Oh my god, did you guys really drop?
Yeah, yeah, you don't know.
This is a pretty far drop, so we'll have to pop our shit pretty early.
That's on them.
They literally did not have to land on us, but they chose that.
They could've chose not to die to us.
They could've chose to literally land anywhere else because there's enough drop spots for them.
That's like the crazy part.
This map is so big.
They literally chose this.
And it's not like Apex where there's like, you know...
They're doing it again.
They're contesting us again.
I see them.
Wait, there's like three people here.
Wait, what?
Wait, there's three.
Why are there so many people contesting us?
What the fuck?
There's all the people.
Where do we go?
Doryu?
No, we're chilling here.
We're chilling here.
That's like two different teams.
Yeah, they're trying to shoot you.
Wait, there's two teams now.
Wait, one is cracked.
36 flesh on them?
I'm like not landing in a good spot.
Oh my god, I almost knocked one.
We get it, we get it.
There's some over there.
I see them.
I'm gonna back just in case because I was getting pushed.
Oh, I got good guns.
I got good guns.
Okay, me too.
Doryu, be careful there.
Be careful.
Me, I'm coming over to you.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Now we have two teams pushing us?
I have a sniper rifle.
What the fuck is wrong with these freaks?
Like, bro, you already got farmed.
Like, get out.
Fucking thank you.
Oh, I was about to shoot this guy.
Wait.
Am I able to?
Oh, damn.
Okay.
Why are so many people here?
Should we go back here?
Is this looted?
Oh.
Cracked?
Wait, wait, wait.
One behind... What?
Oh, my god.
He's behind the tree here.
He's low.
Wait, this is a different team.
This is not theirs.
Yeah, I cracked this one on the left.
Yeah, but they're chasing.
Yeah, lucky FPS.
Yeah, what?
What?
This is a different team.
Why are we getting contested by some random ass other team?
Like, hello?
Where's them?
What?
That's so unfortunate.
Oh my god, that's so unlucky.
We got contested by a new team.
I know, right?
What the... I mean, do you want to just, like, play around?
I feel like we should... I feel like we should... Should we leave it?
Because I feel like now everyone's just dropping on us.
Yeah, like, as much as I don't want to be like, yeah, we ain't no pussy ass bitches.
Yeah, but now we have three teams contesting us.
Yeah, so I'm down.
Let's just say, you know, y'all can, like, literally have that if you think that that's gonna help you.
Yeah, I mean, there's nobody in the mountains.
I actually don't know any of the spots, though, to be fair.
No, no, we can, um... let's see.
I'm trying to think where...
Yeah, yeah, this team is purposely, uh, third-partying.
Wait, that's a different team!
That's third-partying.
Yeah, there's so many teams out here, like, what?
There's so many teams trying to third-party!
What?
Wait, what are we?
I mean, like, are there any livestock to them?
Like...
Like, holy shit!
I can't believe this.
It's like there's so many other spots to go, and everyone's like, yeah, we're just gonna, like, literally throw our game.
Everybody's literally landing, and that's so fucked.
This guy hasn't even fully healed yet.
Wait, what?
This is so fucked.
What?
Everybody, like, wants to cont... cause they're like, oh, two teams are contesting that spot.
We gotta... we gotta fucking contest that.
But, like, what?
Like...
I'm so confused.
I mean, like, what we could take?
Cause, like, I was looking at the map.
Yeah?
If we don't want to deal with all that cringe.
There is, like...
There are a few spots that are right outside... oh, where is ours?
It's, like, near Nitrodome, basically.
And, um...
Oh, there's no Way Thieves in there.
Exactly.
Wait, what?
I stacked it?
Holy shit, people already have, like, gloves and everything.
We can literally take all of that.
We can take... what?
People... what?
These players are...
These players are so weird.
Are they still there fighting?
Um, yeah, I'm just, like, I'm looking around the whole, like, map right now.
I'm trying to find...
Okay, Apply died.
Okay.
That's... that's all I care.
They ran away!
Day 3 and Apply, literally!
Oh, my God.
They, like, ran...
Oh, wait, no.
They, like, ran away.
These guys have been choosing to just fight the entire game.
Like, what?
These guys are playing pubs.
Wait, they actually ran away!
Oh, my God!
That is so funny.
Wait, is this guy seeming alive?
Oh, no.
No, they both are live.
They're both alive.
Oh, okay, okay.
What?
Oh, my God.
These guys actually ran...
This is exactly why we needed safe zones.
Like, to get rid of cringe like this shit.
Like...
Like, because now we are getting landed by two teams.
Like, holy shit.
Like, crazy part is that, like, we honestly, like, just need proper loot.
And we can literally, like, live as long as these guys can.
Yeah, they actually... we got contested.
And then, like, the team Day 3 and Apply literally ran away while we were getting contested.
Yeah, these guys are just kind of, like, W-keying.
I think they just choose a W-key instead of play for, like, placement.
At least the way this guy's playing.
Wait, who are you watching?
I'm watching Bucky.
BuckyFPS.
Oh, Bucky.
No, Bucky dies, like, 20 times yesterday.
Oh, yeah, because that's the guy that we killed yesterday, right?
No, he's... that's the guy that, like, fucking splits from his teammates just to get kills.
And then, like, gets rezzed.
Wait, what?
Because he literally dies.
Yeah, that guy died, like, 20 times...
Like, at least, like, 10 times in one game.
What the...
From one of the games that we were in.
Because I was like, he's still alive?
Like, I would just be watching the fucking game.
And I'm like, wait, he's down.
Wait, he's back.
And then...
Because he... it's a rebooted thing.
Yeah.
Yeah, so then he literally just kept getting rebooted to get kills.
That's the guy you killed last round?
The guy only killed me because he had his other teammate pushing me on the side.
Do you want to actually play a round?
Do you want to play, like, unrated while we're waiting?
Yeah, let's do it.
They don't deserve my views.
Fucing Giga-chan!
Giga-chan is fucked.
Yo, thank you for having vlogs, thank you.
Thank you!
I'm seeing this is the same skin.
I'm wearing this one.
Kill me off early.
I fucking am out.
Can we actually be able to shoot your gun?
And then we can actually, like, WK through this?
Yeah, yeah.
And we can use a vehicle if we want.
Alright, so where are we landing?
Um, okay, so we can practice it right now.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah, I'll ping where we're gonna go to.
Where's the overall stat?
Oh, there's the overall stat.
Oh yeah, we are 15th.
Yeah, we're in 15th.
Yeah.
They just got lucky.
Oh my god!
It's cause they're 20th!
That buck!
That team that pushed us, they were 20th place!
Yeah.
Which is like insane, cause like, doing a child like that, I mean, you know how it is in Apex.
It's literally a 50-50.
Yeah.
It's a matter of whoever gets lucky on their, like, loot.
Yeah, they literally challenged us cause they were 20th place.
Aren't they both pro players?
Yeah, they're both Overwatch players, I think?
No, no, I know the 20th, no, no, the buck guy.
Oh, the 20th?
Oh, buck?
Yeah!
The buck guy!
Aren't they both pro players?
That's embarrassing.
Hate to see it, VTubers are beating them.
That's freaking embarrassing.
I barely shot my gun.
Yeah.
They're not as punk as we are.
This is... Oh, he's a tier one pro.
That is embarrassing.
Dang, what?
That's a tier one pro and they're doing that?
What?
Damn.
All I'm saying is that, like...
This team is literally just one player.
Like...
No, not even.
Not even.
That's what all the other Fortnite pros get for rejecting my... We are one combined brain cell.
...for not wanting to play with me.
I'm gonna drop now.
Alright, we're landing.
So, we're gonna land on... this is gonna be our spot that we can go for.
Oh, okay.
So, the nice thing is that there's, like, loot literally everywhere here and they have the heal cactuses.
So, we never get any heals.
We can basically get the free ones around the map.
So, there's...
So, like, nobody... who's around us?
Um, there's a team at Nitrodome that's gonna be there.
And there's gonna be a team down over here.
That'll be there.
And then, uh...
We have, like, a lot of free rotating space, too.
There's a lot of people here.
Oh, I did not get a gun.
Oh, that is...
Oh, that's not good.
I don't know.
I literally can't even find a gun.
I found a gun.
Oh, I'm probably dead.
Oh, no.
I hear gunshots.
I can't even find a gun!
Where are they?
There's literally no guns!
This guy's, like, on me.
I'm dead.
Woo!
Hey.
Oh, hey.
I'm gonna drink this potion next to you.
Right here?
Oh, he has shields already?
Yeah.
Oh.
I lost him.
I'm just gonna chill in here.
Because, uh... I still have, like... Oh, he has shields already?
He has a fucking shotgun!
Oh!
Okay, I didn't realize he had a shotgun.
I think I'm gonna get blown up here.
How did he land to the...
Why is Wanda using C4 here?
What the fuck?
Wait, you're still alive?
Yeah, I'm in the trash.
Oh, you're a trash.
Oh, my God.
If a straight bullet hits you, you're so fucked.
You had no gun?
I literally had no gun.
I ran around the whole three floors of that building.
And there was no guns anywhere.
And then I got chased by the guy with the shotgun.
Oh, my God.
You almost got shot by that one guy.
Because of the straight bullet.
I don't even know how I'm alive.
Also, why do people land here in pubs?
Wait, what?
I'm so confused.
Is this like a hiding spot in the game?
Yeah, I'm literally just chilling in the trash.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh, is he driving away?
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Why is this guy still here?
Yeah.
Leave.
There's nothing here.
Oh, my God.
Why?
What are you doing here?
Leave.
Oh, are they going to go for that?
Look, there's some delicious rats over there.
That's actually crazy.
What the?
What?
This guy is sweaty.
Holy shit.
These guys are so lucky I did not get a gun.
I would have absolutely destroyed them.
Okay, I'm ready to...
Alright, I'm ready to go.
Oh, did you ready up in there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I accidentally backed out.
Oh, wait, but you're ready.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, does this actually work?
Yeah, yeah, it works.
Yeah!
Are we good?
We're so good.
Okay, I'm trying to look at game four now.
Yeah, I'm going to see what they're doing in the tourney.
Game four is...
What is game four?
Fourth map.
Oh, it's the same.
Wait, what?
Yeah, the matches go really long.
Like, that's why I was like...
Oh, oh, bad weapons.
Oh, you're talking about the next one.
Yeah.
Oh, the safe zone is on!
Safe zone is on!
Oh, sweet!
Okay, sweet.
So, like, do we want to just...
Yeah, we should just land our safe zones on.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we stay there.
Okay, okay.
We might as well if it's on.
Oh, Bucky just died on the...
Fuck you!
I'm pretty sure they got points, though, just because they killed the both of us.
They got two points from that.
Oh, no, never mind.
They're alive.
Wait, what?
I thought they just said they died.
Confusion?
So, there's safe zones.
There's bad weapons.
It's just the rifles, though.
Only the rifles are bad.
Honestly...
Oh, all the rifles?
Oh, okay.
I don't know if it's all of them, but there's a lot of rifles in there.
It's the combat assault, the enforcer, the tactical, the combat, the tri-beam, and the warforged.
Is that all of them?
That's pretty much all of them.
Yeah, I think...
Oh, yeah, so it's just gonna be people sniping, then.
Which is already how, like, Fortnite competitive is.
Ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oh, I need to dance with you!
I'm coming!
Ba-ba-ba-ba.
Alright.
Well, I guess we go back to the ghouls.
Do you wanna go to Grim Gate again?
Yeah, yeah.
We might as well.
It's safe zone, so we should be fine.
Yeah.
Look at you!
You're gonna be, like, a Fortnite pro.
Okay, no, I'm gonna, like, stop touching Fortnite again.
Until there's, like, cool cosmetics.
Yeah, where's our other...
Wait, what other skin do you wanna see in this game?
Me.
Okay, will they add you in?
You're gonna become a Fortnite pro.
I will not play Fortnite until they add me in.
Your move, Fortnite.
Oh?
Yay!
Where are you landing?
Uh, on height.
I'm gonna be here.
Move this one chest.
Oh, I got a portal bunker, nice.
You don't need this.
I believe in you, Doryu.
I got heals!
Here, do you want this?
Oh, here, you can top off with that.
Oh, okay, nice.
You want Nitro Splash?
Uh, no, I'm good.
I know somebody landed here with us.
Yeah.
I knocked one of them.
Whoa!
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me.
Like, I know you fucking gave it to me, but...
I still didn't expect it.
Oh my god, this guy is crawling.
Wait, I hear somebody swimming.
Oh, a ghost ship!
Are there ghosts?
Oh, you got a ghost ship?
Yeah!
Yes!
Here's the ghost ship.
Wait, you know what I wanna try?
Oh my god, Doryu, okay, we have to sign this.
Okay, what is it?
Okay, so like, you have the ghost ship on you, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Stand where I am?
Yeah.
And look this exact direction that I'm looking.
Yeah, like here?
And then summon the ship.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure, I'm gonna do it.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
Oh!
Oh my god!
What's the size?
You break so much of this!
Yeah, I break everything.
Oh my god!
Okay, is it only one use?
Yeah, it's one use, so we don't have it anymore.
Oh!
Okay, I was gonna say, you could literally just destroy this whole entire area.
That's why it's gold.
Oh my god, that's insane!
Okay, alright, noted, noted.
They didn't ban that.
Yeah, they didn't ban that, but they banned the guns.
They didn't ban any of the...
Uh...
Literally any of the fists.
Oh, that's true too.
You can still use the magneto gloves.
Yeah, yeah.
Everyone's just gonna be running that then.
It's gonna be like magneto gloves Um...
There's your port pair torch.
The nitro gloves, and then people just sniping.
Thank you, Tyson!
Uh, okay.
So...
I wonder if it will be a guaranteed spawn?
At like...
One POI for the...
The ship?
The ship, yeah.
I think I've been getting a lot of the ship.
Can you imagine we make it closer to end zone?
And then you basically use that?
Yeah!
Okay, only if we survive.
We gotta survive.
We still need to survive to do that.
We can definitely do it.
I don't know, that's the only issue.
We just gotta live.
If zone pulls to us, I think it's very possible.
I'm pretty confident.
Cause we can carry...
You know, everyone's gonna be using bunkers and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Like we literally just throw the ship down.
Yeah, that's all we gotta do is throw it.
Yeah, we gotta stay in the portabunker.
Wait until...
It's almost end zone.
And then just throw the ship down.
Okay, I'm with it.
I'm with this plan.
Okay, so we're gonna try to find a ship.
How many can you have in your inventory?
Can you have multiple?
Um, I don't know.
I never got a chance to have multiple.
I've only found one.
Well, we are gonna try to see if we can find multiple.
Maybe it's a Pirates of the Caribbean.
A Pirates of the Caribbean map would have one too, maybe.
Oh, that's right!
I haven't even gone to that area yet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna mod the car so you can actually get a turret on it.
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
That's how we saw it from the first game.
Which I wasn't even doing before.
I feel bad cause I never got a chance to shoot it.
It's okay.
It was just not meant to be.
No, it's off-road tires.
This time though...
Oh, it's over.
Oh, shit!
Is he gonna shoot us?
They should!
I'm not trying to get a gun.
Okay, let's get a gun on him.
Oh my god, he's shooting at us!
I can't do anything about it!
I got a turret!
Oh!
Holy shit!
Wait, I think he might kill our car before I get in!
I think he's gonna kill our car.
We have to get out of here.
Okay, I'm out.
I'm out.
I wasn't out.
I was not out, but now I am.
Now I am.
Is he literally still trying to shoot us?
Oh, shit!
It's a pirate ship!
Holy shit, he got up just to shoot us!
Yo, what the?
Where is he?
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Oh, it's Jack Sparrow!
Oh my god, it's Jack Sparrow Jack Sparrow and Barbossa!
No, not Barbossa.
The other guy!
It's the other guy.
That dude.
The one guy.
We didn't need you.
Guys, I'm not a fake fan because I stopped watching it when Jack Sparrow and when Orlando Bloom stopped being in it, so I'm not a fake fan, guys.
I actually forgot that Orlando Bloom wasn't in it anymore.
Was it the fourth movie?
Yeah, it was when he became Davy Jones.
Oh, I forgot about that.
Why is it purple glowing?
Did you grab the...
Did you already grab the... The gloves?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, do you want them?
No, no, it was weird because the purple is still there.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm not a fake fan because I actually stopped watching the movies after they replaced Orlando Bloom.
Because it wasn't a good movie after that.
They're like, yeah, we gotta like throw in the not proper actor for this movie.
And our numbers are gonna do just fine.
Aaron will be okay.
I'm gonna see where this guy died at.
No, that's not true because there was that other girl who I forgot the name of because she wasn't as important as Orlando Bloom.
But like, she also...
Yeah, yeah, her.
She was also equally...
important, but not that important to me.
What was this guy doing?
He's trying to get me over!
That's what he was trying to do!
What the fuck?
Wait, they're gone!
Wait, what's the... Oh wait, the Nitro Fist!
Yeah, those are the...
Do you wanna be Doomfist?
Yeah, yeah, that's Doomfist.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
I got one.
Okay, okay, okay.
You wanna go to the pirate area?
Sure, sure.
I'm not been there yet.
Other than like...
when we...
Okay, left click is forward, alright.
Yeah, when you're in the air, left click launches you up, or launches you in the air.
And then right click is an uppercut.
Okay.
They must have got this pirate ship from here then.
Cause like, Davy Jones had a pirate ship.
Oh, wait, I wonder if they sell it.
Do you think they sell it here?
Wait, wait, there's a car coming over to us.
You have magneto gloves.
Get him.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm getting this.
Get him.
Yeah!
Get him!
Oh, you think you can do that?
And what the... That's fucking right.
I'm gonna fucking speed up.
Oh!
He's trying to beat me up too!
Oh shit!
Oh!
He beat me up!
What the fuck!
The Joker!
Wait, the Joker killed me!
Oh shit!
The Joker destroyed me!
Oh my god!
Wait, did this...
Are they still alive?
Oh, they are!
Yeah, he's trying to save his TV.
He's trying to save his TV right now.
Holy fuck!
I can't believe it!
The Joker got me!
Wait, they're dying!
There's another team!
No, no, there's another team!
Just like the cat in his head!
You Thanos, you gotta get revenge!
You gotta kill the Joker!
You gotta kill the Joker, Thanos!
Where is he?
Oh, they died!
Okay, apparently they died!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, get me back!
I got you, I got you!
Oh my god, this seems so horny for me!
Holy shit!
I can't believe the Joker killed me!
Why are they chasing me?
There's a very fun team you can go kill over there.
Yeah, go get those guys!
Okay, I got you, I got you!
Oh, thank god!
This is our spot!
It's not illegal, Batman!
Live, Doki!
I'm back!
You're back, bitches!
The Joker who laughs!
That's right, I outlived Joker!
I literally outlived him!
What the?
What the fuck?!
I just got here!
That's so fucked up!
Live!
You killed my teammate!
I'm sorry!
Yeah!
I give shit on nerds!
I got you!
I literally lived for five!
I got gold, though!
I got money!
I literally was like...
I literally spawned in and died!
What the fuck is wrong with these people?
Here, I'm gonna give you this!
I have this, yeah.
There you go, there you go.
Make it rain!
Did you already get gloves?
No.
Okay.
Yeah, you can take it out.
Wait, there's a car here.
What the fuck?!
Oh no, I might die.
No, you're good, you're good, you're good.
Oh god.
No.
I don't feel good.
They left, they left.
I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good for you.
Doki, have you seen a dog?
No!
Doki!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, there's a car in front of me.
There's a car in front of you.
Oh, woah, woah, woah.
Oh, woah, woah.
There's so many things.
Oh, the car is coming!
Oh shit, I'm coming Doki!
I'm coming!
Oh god.
You're living, you're living, you're living.
I'm fucking trying my best.
You're so alive, I've never seen you more alive.
Oh god.
Thank god.
Oh thank god.
Don't look at me, please.
Don't look at me.
Oh.
I'm here.
I found so many medkits.
I'm here Doki.
I'm okay, I feel so alive.
I've never felt so alive in my life.
We're here.
I'm here.
We're so alive.
You wanna get the Baja Blast?
Yeah, let's go get some Baja Blast.
Let's go get some Baja Blast.
So how was that adventure?
I'm gonna go for this thing right now, real quick.
Yay!
Is someone shooting at you?
Oh no, that's other dudes.
I've been trying not to look behind me.
Never look back, Doki.
If I don't look, they don't exist.
Never look back.
Oh hey, Nuka Cola.
Nuka Cola, Nuka Cola.
I'll grab this.
I'm gonna grab a Nuka Cola.
I'm gonna pop it right now.
I have Nitro.
Do you want Nitro?
No, I'm good.
Oh okay, nevermind.
I guess I'm not good.
Oh there's people here.
What the?
They're going up.
Doki, come over here.
We're gonna go in this together, okay?
Yeah.
And then there's dudes like right here.
Let's line right here.
Alright, I'm in.
What the?
What the fuck?
You're good.
He's one.
No, I missed.
Wait, is he gonna die from fall damage?
No, no, no.
Wait, I got him.
He's knocked.
Where's his teammate?
Wait, what the fuck?
He rode all the way up.
He had footsteps.
I'm here.
His teammates are here.
Fuck you, I'm gonna fist you.
I didn't kill you, but I'm gonna fist you just for the sake of it.
Where did he go?
Oh, he's like over here.
Hey, I messed up my fists.
I could've killed him off in time.
Oh my god.
We are believing.
We died from fall damage.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Where are you?
I'm above.
I'm getting shot by some other team.
They're being really ugly.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, the code's up.
The code's up.
Oh shit, the code's up.
We should leave.
Actually, let me die in the same.
Okay, okay.
I left.
Oh, I left already.
The code's been up for three.
Oh my god, it's been up for three.
Wait, did we miss it?
Did we miss it?
No, no, no.
We're good.
Okay, I'm claiming stuff.
Okay.
Are we good?
Uh, they haven't said anything yet.
They haven't said anything yet.
We're good.
Wait, did you?
I readied up.
Okay, you readied up.
Readied up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alright, let's bring Goku and Vegeta in.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
They didn't notice, guys.
They didn't notice.
You know how Goku out to get some to go off right now?
I got Goku.
So you gonna wear Goku?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want me to wear Bulma?
Oh, Bulma or Vegeta?
I'll be Vegeta.
I'll be...
Oh my god, they don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have Vegeta.
They don't know.
I'll have a big-ass forehead.
They never, they never know.
They didn't know they were waiting for us.
We're too busy fisting.
I purposely died there, chat, cause I knew.
I saw the, I saw the notification.
Yeah?
So I was like, looking at my Discord when I was following, and I was like, oh, and then I purposely died.
Cause I knew that if I died, we could leave the lobby.
Jay wants to fight you both to the death.
Jay wants to fight us to the death.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Where?
I don't know, that's what some of my chat said.
Oh, cause I was shit talking?
They just want to fight us to the death.
Safe zone, you idiots.
You can't.
You guys are in 18th and Jay's in 19th.
Well, if they do, then they get minus 10 points, and then we like say extra good.
You know what, say yes and then, and then so they can get minus 10 points.
Oh, we're going in!
We're going in!
We agree to it, Ninja.
We just let them kill us, so they lose 10 points.
Ew.
Is that Blue Condom?
Yeah, that's them.
That's them.
They're monkeys.
They're the monkeys.
Wait, can you...
Oh, they all bought the fucking...
The condoms are blue now.
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, we can't...
No until...
Until Zone 2, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Not until Zone 2.
Alright, drop.
Now.
Alright, nice.
Doki, I'm holding your virtual flesh-tuber hand.
Alright, here we go.
Hoping that we don't die immediately.
Virtual flesh-tuber hand?
That does not make sense.
Oh, no!
I didn't think... Some of my chat said it's a Smurf brand condoms.
No!
Why would you say that?
That makes me so much worse.
No!
Oh, they don't have the thing where you can, like, look above you.
Or something.
Yeah, you can't, like, free look or whatever.
Yeah, free look.
We don't have free look here.
Alright, we in this.
We're sharing.
There's also no rifles, right?
Yeah, no rifles.
We're sharing.
Sharing is caring, guys.
Sharing is caring.
Woo!
Oh, what'd I get?
Wait, so that means that, like...
Okay, so just SMGs and shotguns and stuff?
Oh, wait, I just forgot.
Yeah, yeah.
DMR and then, uh...
I guess I can use... Wait.
Is there a chest here?
Nah, there's no chest.
Woo!
I'm getting so many repair tools.
Oh, that's not what we needed.
I know, right?
Wait, are they shooting?
No, I actually shot my gun.
That was...
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, Nuka-Cola.
Nuka-Cola.
Oh, do you need a big?
Uh...
No.
Okay, okay.
I can drink this Nuka-Cola now.
Should I drink it?
Is it worth it?
Yeah, you can drink it now.
Nuka-Cola.
Oh, I got shocky walkies!
Let's go!
Alright, so there's just gonna be peace until Zone 2.
It's so weird.
Yeah, Zone 2.
It's gonna be peaceful.
We come in peace.
Literally.
Oh, we can't... We can use the laser rifle, right?
Yeah!
Wait, uh...
Let me see.
I have the other... Oh, no, you can't.
You can't.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, no.
Uh...
Oh, there's a sniper rifle.
Oh, there's a... There's a nitro!
Nitro!
Come here!
Oh, you got a nitro?
Oh, you should get it.
You should get it.
Wait, you don't want that?
No, no, no.
You should get it.
I believe in you with it.
No, after what I did with the nitro... with the nitro fist, you should have it.
What are you... You want shockwaves then?
Did you say you have movement?
Uh, sure.
I'll take it.
Okay.
Is there a chest here?
Holy shit.
Uh, how are you on ammo right now?
Are you pretty good?
I'm pretty... Oh.
I think so.
I wonder where these guys are gonna be.
I'll grab this.
Oh, more shockwaves?
Oh, that's good.
I'll take it.
I'll grab some ammo here.
What is this?
Oh, I'm gonna grab... Man, I'm getting the same SMG.
Wait, somebody died.
Wait, what?
Uh... Somebody got rebooted.
Did they accidentally kill...
I think they accidentally killed them.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe.
Uh, do you want the bubbles at all?
Uh, I can carry the bubbles.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have, uh... I have the houses.
Uh...
Yeah, I have houses too.
You can do some of my houses here.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm down.
Dang, there's really no, uh...
There's no pirate ships.
Yeah, maybe they took the pirate ships.
Um...
Well, I mean, we could wait here.
Or we could just move towards, like, a better spot in the zone.
Maybe.
I feel like we should be in zone before it's zone 2.
Yeah, let's... Let's go prioritize getting in zone.
Yeah.
What?
Okay, we have, like, a minute before zone 2, I guess.
Let's, uh... go this way, then?
We have the medkit.
Just remember to touch the water before we, like, leave this area.
Yeah.
Are we good?
Oh, I wish they'd bring back the Dragon Ball Z items.
The fucking cloud was so strong.
I think it's gonna come back again.
I'm pretty sure, like, I saw, like, a post about, like, it coming back.
Oh, that'll be fun.
Um... What do you think?
Zone's ending.
I am the worst at calling zones in this game.
I mean, like, I have a feeling of it going probably...
Actually, no.
I can't tell in zone 1.
Like, once it starts shrinking down, you can start, like, Yeah, but then in zone 2, that's when they start shooting.
Yeah.
I think what we can do for now... In 26 hours...
We should have a place before they start shooting.
Oh, there's a team in there.
Yeah, they might chase after us.
Let's back up.
Let's go over here.
Okay, cause I feel like their moment...
Yeah, we have 15 seconds.
That team's gonna chase us.
Oh, I'm so far.
You can burn a shockwave.
Burn one shockwave.
Okay.
I need to run up before I can burn it.
I'm gonna make sure that this PLY's clear before...
Cause I can look down for you.
Is it clear?
Uh...
Oh my god, people started fucking fighting.
Is it?
I don't hear anyone, but...
I'm trying to like...
Team behind you!
Team literally behind you!
Oh yeah, I see him.
Okay, I'm gonna drop down.
I'm gonna go.
I'm going your way.
Okay, go that way.
Go that way.
Literally saw them running at you when the moment zone closed.
I wonder if they like saw me beforehand.
I don't know.
That's scary.
Where should we go?
Oh yeah, I see him on the mountain.
Where should we go now?
Oh, I have no sight on this guy.
Uh, I mean we can like...
go back here?
Yeah, I mean it's still in zone.
Wait, they dropped a crown here.
Yeah, a lot of people dropped crowns.
Uh...
There was fighting to our south?
So, oh, team here.
I see them.
Wait, it's them!
125!
125.
Oh, you cracked them?
Yeah, I cracked one.
I did 125 on one of them too.
They're inside here?
That's them.
That's literally them.
Oh, one going on height.
I'm above.
I don't see them.
Oh, I'm not with you.
Cracked?
You're good.
I almost knocked one.
They're really, really I didn't even get cracked yet.
They're down here?
They regrouped?
They're... I think they're just healing.
They're healing right now.
You have to, yeah.
I'm like looking behind in this just in case.
Do you wanna like rotate to zone now?
Or do you wanna just commit to this fight?
I don't mind either.
What do you think is the best idea?
Start going this way.
I'm looping.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Yeah, now they don't have...
They don't have heals now.
I think we should be okay.
I think.
Is this a sniper rifle?
No, I can't grab that either.
Oh!
Over across?
Oh, shit.
Go back.
Oh, I don't think I can.
Oh, I couldn't.
Yeah.
You're good.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna get chased so hard.
Yeah, you are.
Oh, there is a whole lot of other team here.
I'm looking for you.
They're right here.
They have fists too.
They have fists.
Yeah, I just have a whole other team on me here.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Do they have the magneto gloves?
I'm so jelly.
I don't know.
Are they still chasing you?
Oh, you're so lucky, man.
Oh, no.
That's so unlucky.
We ran into a different team.
We ran into another team.
That's so unlucky.
I should just chill in the bunk.
I just need to heal.
I just need to keep on healing.
Yeah.
Not last though.
Definitely not last.
We were just unlucky.
We bumped into another team.
I guess we probably should just commit.
There's other people pulling up though for the fight.
Yeah.
I think we should have like... because like is the next game also safe zone?
It is.
Let's see.
Safe zone... off.
No.
There's no safe zone.
Okay.
I'm gonna read the next one.
Because I feel like if next...
Okay.
The last game is safe zone.
Oh, no.
Game 5, we have to land on the hot zone.
Oh, that's what we have to do.
Yeah.
So we just land on hot zone and leave again.
But I think like for safe zone, I think we should like land, loot, and then get to like a house to live in.
Or like... Yeah.
I think what we need to do is we need to grab a car.
Oh, that's right.
I forgot.
Yeah.
You guys should definitely fight.
I mean, we did.
I was owning them.
I literally cracked both.
I almost knocked one.
Yeah.
We did.
I did 125.
I think maybe we should have committed that then.
I could have, but like...
You probably would have had to be like directly on me.
Because like if I had pushed them, I would have gotten double teamed.
Yeah.
Because like I did 144 to one of them.
And then I did, I think like...
Yeah.
I did 125 on the other.
Oh, that means they're both one-shot.
Yeah.
Well, one was one-shot at first.
And then the other one was getting an advantage point.
Or whatever.
So...
Yeah.
We definitely could have jumped on them.
Definitely.
It's okay.
I mean, we can play our own match again if we want.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Okay.
Alrighty.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
I'm sorry I accidentally muted.
Welcome back!
Yay!
So what's the strat for next game?
So the strat for next game is...
We can land pretty much at the corner of the front of the ship.
Okay.
Because there is a ring that we can take that will give us nitro.
And it will launch us as well.
Oh, okay.
I feel like one of the other teams would want to do that too.
I feel like they would.
Because the hard part is like if we land safely on the corners that's also a viable strat too.
But like if we don't get any movement and someone else does, we're basically just dead.
Yeah.
So...
It could be like kind of chaotic if we just land at the ring and then we just keep on running for wherever the nearest safe zone is.
Oh, okay.
Also I'm ready to play some pubs while we wait.
This is going to take a while.
Alright, here.
Lay back out.
I feel like this is longer.
They made it so much longer.
Yeah, it's also because in Reload Reloaded is like way faster too.
Yeah, this is such a...
I thought Day 2 was five games instead of six.
That's what I thought too.
Yeah.
They added an extra... Why did they add an extra game?
Why did...
I'm pretty sure all the FNCS players are like we just wanted to make more money in the other place.
But it's the same money.
Why did they add an extra game?
Yeah, what?
I thought it was five games.
When did it became six games?
Our souls are binded even longer.
When did they add an extra game?
We have to suffer for one more.
No, two more.
There's still two more games left.
We're doing it for the vibes.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
That's our priority.
You know what's wild?
What?
Jay's team, we like own them pretty hard.
Yeah.
We just got third.
Like we got caught by a different team.
I think what they were going to wait for is for us to push them on the inside.
Like they're probably going to hold inside and start holding corners or whatever.
Yeah.
But like a valid play that you can do with shockwaves is you can break walls.
You can break through walls or whatever.
Yeah, I had shockwaves.
We could have done that.
Yeah.
You're literally going to be a pro.
Watch, I'm calling it.
No, this is the last game.
A doggy skin is going to happen.
What?
And then you're going to be a pro.
No.
Wait, what do you mean?
I'm snacking right now.
I didn't have lunch.
What?
You didn't have lunch?
I didn't have lunch.
I went straight to this tournament.
I happily eat some popcorn.
I love popcorn.
Popcorn is my craft.
Goku!
Hello.
Vegeta!
Oh my god, this is why we didn't win.
We didn't power up.
I'm constipated.
And then Super Saiyan.
Look, we got blue hair now.
Oh, now I don't have a shirt.
You can't go beyond me.
That's right.
This is why you'll never be better than me.
Vegeta.
You can't go shirtless.
My forehead is bigger than yours.
You can never go shirtless and that's why you'll never be better than me.
What do you mean?
I can go shirtless.
Bulma can attest to it.
No, the Saiyan suit stays on.
Bulma's into that shit.
Bulma's like, I only take big strong Saiyans.
Do you want to go to Nitro Dome?
Let's go to Nitro Dome.
Oh wait, actually no.
We can practice this.
Oh yeah, yeah.
There's going to be so many dudes here.
We're probably going to insta-die right now because we're so late.
That's fine.
Okay, so do you see the red thing though?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what we're going to land on.
We're going to land literally on that.
What am I eating guys?
I'm eating those little like...
The Meji chocolate.
The rainbow one.
With the Marble.
Oh, that sounds so good.
It's like a classic kid's chocolate.
Wait, what?
Did no one like go here?
I guess not.
I don't see anybody.
So...
What we'll do...
Oh no, there's people fighting here.
So what we'll do is we'll just basically land here on the little ring.
Yeah, and then we peace out.
Yeah, we just hop out.
That's all we're going to do.
And then we just keep running.
Alright, I'm going to grab a gun.
Let's kill this.
Let's kill them right now.
Nuka-Cola.
Goku's got the nukes.
What the?
Goku's ready.
Oh, what the fuck, Richard?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, I'm dead.
I got shot by like two teams.
Haha, it's my car now.
Oh, did you?
Yeah, you can drive over my car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, where's your car?
It's right there.
Oh.
Did I get it?
No.
Goddamn!
Okay, good.
Okay, round two.
Oh, you got that.
Did I get it?
Round three.
I know you said I could drive over the car.
I'm literally over it.
You have to go a little more to the right.
Yeah, yeah, right there.
There we go.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye.
Round three.
It's round three.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
How many cars are here?
Leave me alone.
Oh my god, you're so popular.
How do I nitro boost?
They want Goku's autograph.
Oh, you just shift.
You just shift.
Oh, just shift?
Okay.
That's fucking right.
I saved my nitro for this.
Oh, god.
Oh, they're all just...
Oh, no.
Not yet.
Oh, you're good.
I'll bring him to the other car.
Oh, run over the...
Oh, you missed it.
It's okay.
You're good.
Get out of the car.
It's okay.
Oh, my.
Fuck you.
No, John Wick.
You're better.
Of course, it's John Wick.
Of course, John Wick would chase Goku.
You were only trying to snatch up Bulma.
Oh, my god.
You know, they're pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
What if you were actually just better, though, Dokie?
They were pretty... No, they were just bad.
You're just simply better.
I lived for so long for two of these people.
Wait.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I'm gonna stay right here, though.
Alright, guys.
Why are Fortnite players so sweaty?
Why did they...
I can't believe they complained about the cars.
I can't believe it.
No fun.
They got rid of the cars.
No fun allowed.
This game was built off of kids' monies.
Like...
Sorry.
Kids' money.
Literally.
This game was built off of children.
And I can't have fun?
Children funded this game.
You're right.
Parents' money.
How dare they.
Alright.
I guess we're landing back here.
No!
It can be fun to play!
It can be!
Did you not see what they did with the cars?
That shit looks so fun!
And then they took it out the moment I realized how fun it could be.
They took it out.
They didn't want me to have fun.
I can't believe it.
That's so messed up.
They took away the one thing I'd feel joy.
The one thing they knew I'd feel joy.
And they wouldn't even let me have the car.
That's the most fucked up part.
I was like, let me have the car at least.
Like, what am I gonna do with it?
What can I do with it?
I'm back!
Welcome back.
I killed a guy.
Oh, you killed a dude?
Yeah, fuck this guy.
That's my fucking teammate right there.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
I don't think he was ready to see me get a fucking shotgun.
I don't know if this is...
There's people fighting.
I see a dude that I'm landing close to.
That's me.
That is not me.
That was 100%.
Surely I'll get a gun, right?
Surely.
Oh, I got a gun.
I see people on my end.
Oh my god, it's Deadpool!
Yo, Deadpool?
Deadpool's here with his Wait, didn't the movie come out today?
I don't remember.
No, I just saw Deadpool come over here.
But...
I'm gonna slurp.
Yo, we good.
He's above me.
There's a car?
There's a guy above me.
Oh, I hear the car.
There's so many footsteps, I don't like it.
Oh my, what the?
Cowboy lady, what?
Wait, what?
Oh!
I got shot on my side.
I wish I had a shotgun.
Oh wait, no, that's not Deadpool.
That's just a lady.
That's just a woman.
No, she has Deadpool pants.
Oh, does she?
Does she?
I can't tell.
Movie's next week?
Oh, it's next week.
Oh, I thought it was this week.
I'm so dumb.
Oh, the game's about to end.
Oh, okay.
I'm watching Rivals right now.
Oh, somebody got killed early?
Ooh, there's drama!
Ayo?
Wait, oh, are you reading the Rivals show?
Apparently, the caster on stream said kills weren't allowed, and then, but the kills were allowed.
So people got confused.
Wait, what?
No!
Yeah, so people were like, wait, the knife got killed for no reason, and then later I'm like, sorry, caster made a mistake.
Dang.
You were allowed to be killed by then.
Wait, but like, how would they know from the caster?
Like, cause, does that mean that they're like, they just have the Twitch room on the other monitor?
Cause maybe like, maybe like somebody said, wait, they're not supposed to kill you.
Like, someone in the chat said that.
Oh, probably.
And was like, they're not supposed to kill you!
We get killed cause on Twitch Rivals they said they killed us early.
Yeah, yeah.
Somebody said they got killed off early.
But, they weren't.
But then it was like a caster mistake.
Ohhhh.
Just a caster mistake.
Oh, I should go back to the lobby.
Okay, only some died.
Maybe Goku and Vegeta is just cursed.
Like, maybe.
Vegeta do be having a big head.
I don't know about Goku.
Maybe, play your main.
What's your main skin?
My main?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe that's it.
It's cause you're not on your main skin.
I could...
Oh, I don't know which one we're on.
Wait, what's your main skin?
Anything.
I'm gonna match whatever skin you have.
What is this?
Is this FNCS?
Is that the Fortnite Cup?
Oh, that's the tournament that they have right after.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
FNCS, yeah.
That's what they're talking about.
Yeah, that's what the fucking nerds were talking about.
The shop refreshed for FNCS?
FNCS?
Who the fuck is gonna buy it?
I'm sorry, that's so toxic.
Tell him, Doki!
Let him have it!
Who's gonna buy these skins?
Sorry, that's really toxic.
All I'm saying is that it's not even...
I would totally gift you the shark skin if I could.
But I have to wait one more day.
They need like, okay, all I'm saying is that if they're gonna do an actual, like, Fortnite Cup skin, just make it a condom skin and then have the FNCS at the back.
Right, yeah.
That's what they all want.
They're not gonna put the skin on.
Everybody knows it.
Look at the hitbox.
Why is it a guy?
The guy model has big hitboxes.
It should have been a woman.
Are you talking about the dude?
The dude with the big ass jacket?
Yeah, the big ass jacket.
Competing players aren't gonna put the skin on.
It should be literally the condom skin in these colors.
And it should have boobs because apparently the women version has, like, the smallest hitbox.
I can tell them.
Tell them.
Oh my god.
That's all I'm saying.
They should just have the FNCS at the back with the condom skin.
Is anyone gonna get this, like, FNCS hoodie guy?
Yeah.
They're not gonna wear it.
You know the craziest thing?
Like, Fortnite players would buy so many skins, but the only skin they're gonna put on is the fucking condom skin.
Like, that's the craziest shit for me.
They would spend so much money on all these, like, themed skins, but they're just gonna run, like, one skin in the end.
I've always literally told others, like, you can be sweaty and wear whatever skin you want.
You can make Goku sweaty.
No, cause the hitbox!
Goku's hitbox is terrible!
That's why!
His shoulders are ugly.
That's the only thing bad about Goku.
And then the fact that he has a big outline.
Money, Batman.
Okay, what's your main skin?
Uh...
I can be the werewolf, dude.
Alright, then I'll be Tiger Man.
Or wait, or the Lieutenant John Lama?
What?
You have Lieutenant John Lama?
Yeah, is he, like, rare?
I'm so joey.
Is he rare?
He's like an OG skin.
Oh, he's an OG skin?
Yeah.
Since when?
I've always wanted that skin.
I think it's, like, chapter two, I think.
When did this skin come out?
I think it was chapter two, like, early season or something.
It's chapter three, season one.
Oh, chapter three.
Dang.
When was chapter three?
I think that was the chapter when Zero Build came out.
Oh!
Zero Build came out, like, way later.
I think it was, like, chapter three, season three?
Oh!
Yeah, guys.
And then...
I have chapter... I have a rare skin.
That's fucking right.
Wait, is the code out yet or not?
No, it's not.
Okay.
Zero Build was, uh, started as an LTM?
Yeah, that's why I only played it for, like, a little bit.
I think that's why I got him.
I got him because I was like, oh, LTM.
Oh!
Was he around during the LTM?
I think so.
Was it?
Well...
And I missed out on getting... Oh, I probably, like, didn't even buy the battle pass at the time.
Maybe.
I think you didn't get the battle pass, yeah.
Because he must be a battle pass skin.
Yeah.
I remember thinking, like, I'm not gonna play Fortnite.
I'm not gonna main this game.
I'm gonna go back to Apex.
I mean, you're not really maining this game.
You're still not really.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna have... I only play a little bit.
Brian on the back.
Oh, what are you playing on the back?
I'm playing Brian.
Brian?
Yeah.
Oh, you have the little, like, pinata Brian.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
I can put, uh...
I mean, I have the Brian, too.
I can put the Brian on.
Or I could put, um... No, put your main.
Put your main.
Maybe that's why.
You put all your main stuff on, and then maybe...
All my main stuff?
Yeah, put every main stuff in there.
Uh, okay.
For good luck.
That's the good luck charm.
Yeah.
I bet.
If we can't win... No, if we can't get past top 15 with that, then it's just... Then it was just meant to be.
Okay, think of it this way, though.
We got 15th for a short period of time.
That's true.
We had 15th locked.
Yeah.
Until everyone started trying to grief us.
And then until everybody tried, like, knew what skins we were in and just went straight for us.
Everyone.
They don't hate us!
It's not fair!
Do you have any, like, girl skins?
Uh...
I don't think I... Yeah, I do, but they're not cool.
Well, what's, like...
What's the most uncool one that you have?
I'm, like, curious if it's, like, one of the...
If it's uncool, it means it's sweaty.
If it's uncool?
Yeah, it's uncool.
They're all uncool.
That means they're all sweaty.
I mean, they look good.
But, like, they're not, like...
Like, what's the word?
They're not, like, themed.
Yeah, they have cool designs, but they're not, like, themed to anything.
They're, like, Fortnite original characters.
Like, they're Fortnite OCs.
So, like, it's not cool.
Like, who wants to run Fortnite OCs?
When you can run fucking...
Okay, to be fair, Lieutenant John Lama is a Fortnite OC.
But, like, who wants to run Fortnite OCs when I can be literally John Cena, like...
That's all I'm saying.
Honestly, Fortnite players need to listen to your stream.
Yeah.
I think you'll inspire them.
I think Fortnite players are gonna hate me.
They'll hear what you're saying and be like, you know what?
Doki is right.
I think I need to listen to Doki's word.
Apex should also have these types of... like, Overwatch is starting to do, like, crossover skins.
Like, the Optimus Prime Overwatch skin is pretty dope.
But, like, Apex doesn't... I guess Apex did the Final Fantasy, but it's not the same.
They still made it... they made it too serious.
The problem that, like, Apex always does is they, like...
They do the whole...
They keep everything, like, Apex-y.
Yeah, yeah.
And then they, like, don't have fun with it.
Yeah, like, do what Call of Duty does.
They did and fucking put Nicki Minaj in there.
Like, just literally Nicki Minaj.
I literally want Nicki Minaj.
I only want to main that skin.
I like how they literally just put Nicki Minaj in the game.
Like, there's nothing different.
It's literally Nicki Minaj and also Snoop Dogg.
I got those skins so fast when I found out they were in-game.
Okay, we got code.
Nice.
You guys are 19th, but still above Jay?
Let's go Doki!
We're not dead last!
Wait, that means you're 20th.
Wait, they're 20th?
What's the fucking points for them?
Yeah, wait.
What are they getting?
What are they doing?
Are they getting one point?
Every time?
What?
Do they even play, like, Fortnite?
Wait, somebody got minus one.
Somebody got minus ten.
Oh, that's because they killed last game.
Remember when you were like, wait, they're rebooting.
Oh, wait.
But how are we above Jay then?
Oh, because he got one point.
Wait, so...
So, how are we, like, 19th if...
if somebody literally got minus ten?
Oh, because... Oh, they had high placement.
Okay, no...
Oh, they went...
They lost...
They only lost... Oh, they were third place.
That's why.
That makes much more sense.
Wait, they are 20th.
We also... We got, like, a bunch of kill points?
Yeah.
We've gotten, like, three.
Yeah, so they...
I mean, we gotta get that plus two.
They're literally getting points from the safe zone.
That's it.
They've been getting 1-1-1 this entire time.
Oh, that's what it is.
I'm gonna guess that they probably get jumped?
And then they're pretty much like, oh, well, GG.
Okay, all we need is, like, either a kill point or a placement.
And then we'll be safe.
We literally...
The team above us has the same points as us.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
They're literally eight points.
What?
Okay.
Alright.
Doable?
Yeah, it's workable.
It's workable.
Wait, we got this?
We just gotta survive.
That's it.
Survive.
That's literally it.
I love how the whole tourney now is basically Jay versus Doki.
They started it!
They literally contested us!
Yeah, we were vibing.
We did nothing to anyone.
We were fucking vibing.
All we wanted was a pirate ship and some gloves to fit.
Yeah, and then they stayed there?
Like, who does that?
Like, we didn't wanna start this fight.
They threw the first rock.
Actually, yeah, you're right.
They literally threw the first rock.
We were literally chillin', and then you're like, wait.
Wait, why is there people here?
And then they shot at us.
Yeah!
And then they shot at us, and then one of them tried to flank me!
And then we were like, nah, bitch.
And then my bodyguard came over.
Got one.
It was like...
It was like, drop down, Doki!
Get down, Mrs. Doki President!
You were... No, I didn't.
I was very nice throughout this entire tournament.
I was very nice.
I was a nice person.
We've done nothing but be nice.
Yeah, we literally was in our own...
We were in our own lane, and then fucking J3... All the condoms.
Then J3, like, like, fucking bursted in, and was like, I wanna be here too.
Like, they're...
What's it called when somebody, like, um, when somebody like, lives at your place for free?
Squatters!
They're literally squatters!
Oh, squatters!
They're squatters!
That's my house!
We claimed it first!
Yeah, what the...
Yeah, we're the ones that pay rent at your gate.
They're squatters!
We paid rent there!
And then they attracted all the other pro players, cause they're like, look at the 19th and 20th plays fighting each other.
So everyone's just bullying the kids at the playground.
Dude, then they all come to us!
You know, it's so fucking, like, you know what's even funnier about that too?
Remember when you were like, they're running up on you when I was, like, going up the hill?
Yeah!
They were literally watching us go back to Grim Gate the entire time.
And then they watched us fight.
And then another team pulled up to watch us fight.
I'm gonna use that term now and be like, stop fucking squatting on our POI.
We pay for this.
Yeah!
You just contest people?
You don't do that!
That's so fucked.
I'm gonna gritty on them.
Are we a lot of gritty?
We can gritty on people, right?
Yeah, we're a lot to emote on them.
Alright, we're gonna gritty on people.
Well, if we can kill somebody, like... Okay, if we kill Jay again, we're gonna...
We're gonna do the gritty.
We're gonna do the Fortnite dance.
I'm gonna get some pho for dinner.
Oh!
I've been craving some pho.
I love pho.
Alright, I'm gonna reward myself.
Okay, Dory, we have to be a higher placement than Jay, okay?
Okay, we're gonna be a higher placement.
Like, you gotta promise me.
Oh, there's James!
Wait, there's another John Llama!
Wait, who's this?
Who's this?
This one's a purple.
Wait, is this the OG John Llama?
Because he's purple.
And that's the OG.
I'm just the imposter.
They're just looking at each other.
They're like, same person.
Okay, so remember, we're gonna land on the thingy.
Yeah.
We got this?
I don't know, but okay.
Dory, um, to motivate you, I will not get pho if we're not above Jay.
No!
Okay, we're gonna beat them right now.
I will not get pho.
We are getting you that pho.
Did you?
Oh my god, you fucking dropped already.
I was, like, looking.
I was like, did you drop this?
I wasn't even mine!
That's someone else's crown.
Why am I looking at this die?
Like, I didn't know where you were.
I was, like, trying to find you.
No, I was like, where are you?
I couldn't find you.
Oh my god, please.
Please tell me I make it.
So, uh...
Everybody has that strat, I don't...
So, uh... I don't know if the strat is, like, I don't know if the strat is, like, a good strat.
Uh, I mean, we get- Oh!
Don't get a gun idea!
What?
Oh, no, no, don't do that.
Do the same strat, do the same strat, do the same strat, do the same strat.
Okay, um... No, we're not doing it!
I'm scared.
Oh my god!
I'm still drifting down.
I couldn't adjust it.
There was nothing I could do.
I was like, I don't think this is...
I was like doing this.
I was like, I don't like this strap because of that.
Wait, you're not allowed to be on the car!
I forgot, I forgot, I forgot.
I'm dead.
Oh no!
No!
It's okay, we got two points.
We got two points.
Wait, how did you die?
I got chased by the guy that killed you.
Wait, what?
Why wasn't you got chased?
I was gonna literally go to grab your card.
Wait, you came back?
Why did you come back?
Cause I was gonna catch you.
You could have lived!
I can't believe you came back.
I'm not getting far today apparently, guys.
Guys, I'm not getting far.
I can't believe you went back.
I wasn't gonna leave you behind.
I was gonna get you.
You should have left me behind for Fa!
You should have You should have left me behind!
Fa was more important!
He was so much more important!
Noooo!
I knew I fucked up when I was like I'm slowly drifting down.
Well, do you wanna go play a match?
Yeah, let's play a match.
They don't deserve my views.
They don't.
Okay, look, the last game, it's all on you.
The last game we have...
If I die, don't come back for me.
But I can't leave you behind.
You have to or I'm never getting Fa.
I will do it for the Fa.
I will only get for Fa.
That'll be the only thing.
Otherwise, never leave.
You have to leave me or I'll never get it.
Never leaving a John Cena behind, ever.
How does John Cena leave himself behind in the first place?
What do you mean?
I'm not John Cena.
I'm fucking Lieutenant Lam or whatever.
Yeah, but what if John Cena's under that though?
John Llama?
No, there's no way.
Because then why could we see him?
But why is his name John?
John Wick John too.
I mean, maybe...
Maybe I'll be the first skin I ever bought.
Yo, I have that skin too.
This is the first skin I ever bought.
Wait, really?
Yo, alright, alright.
I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
For the final match, maybe this will actually bring me luck.
The very first skin I ever bought.
We're both gonna be candy cane men.
Or John Cena's under here.
Come on, leave me.
No, we have small hitboxes now.
Look, our hitboxes.
Oh, you have the snake!
Wait, why are you like the same?
We're gonna be nerds.
Only nerds have the same skin, remember?
Oh shit, no!
No, we're nerds!
We became the thing we hated the most!
Wait, do you have a different thing?
Oh, you have a pickle rick on your back.
Yeah, the pickle rick.
Yeah, but we're the same!
We're fucking nerds now!
I don't have a pickle rick on my back, though!
No!
Pickle rick was the first backpack I ever bought.
I can't remember what the first one I ever bought was, too.
I think it might have been a...
Wait, no.
I got it way later.
Wait, where do you wanna go?
Do you wanna go here?
Wait, where do you land?
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's just fight.
Okay, let's go to Nitrodome.
Let's just fucking fight.
Yo, what's up, nerds?
Oh my god, if I could, I would wear a condom skin, too.
I feel like the moment you wear the condom skin, people would think you're, like, a tryhard and they're scared of you.
Oh, that's always what they do.
Yeah, like, I wish I had it just to, like, pretend to be, like, a tryhard.
No, don't say that!
So people would run away.
So people would run away when they see it.
It's, like, the only reason why I want it on.
The psychological battle, exactly.
Oh my gosh, which one is the gun?
Oh, they're there it is.
I got a gun.
Ooh, I hear people fighting.
Okay.
Undead Badger?
Alright.
That has to be a bot.
There's no way this guy's real.
Like...
I refuse to believe some guy actually named himself Undead Badger.
Wait, are you okay over there, Dorio?
Yeah, I was muted.
Yeah, you were muted.
I was so muted?
I was like, wait, what if the guy's an Undead Badger?
I was like...
What if he enjoys Undead Badgers?
There's no way.
Bot names are always, like, two... an adjective and a noun.
Essentially, like, bot name 101.
Wait, are you...
Oh, I'm coming over.
Oh, I just... I almost killed this guy.
Where is he?
Get that fucker.
Yeah, come here, bitch.
Yeah, come over here.
I got bullied by pro players, so I'm gonna bully you now.
It's a cycle.
Yeah, I got him.
It's a fucking cycle.
You can never stop it.
Oh my god, he had such a good gun?
Hello?
Uh-huh.
I need, like, shields.
Oh, I got shields.
I can toss you, too.
Oh, I see someone on me.
I see someone on me.
Yeah.
I'm here.
Wait.
I don't know.
Did he see me?
They're coming upstairs?
Where did he go?
Oh, he ran this way.
Wait.
No, that's a bot.
Wait, what?
Where's this other guy at?
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here.
Yes, I'm true.
Oh, I cracked.
I shot the wrong guy.
I shot the bot.
He's gonna kill me.
Wait, no.
You got him.
Wait, I'm gonna shoot the bot.
I'm gonna shoot the bot.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got the bot so I could steal his gun.
It was planned.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Now they all wanna kill me.
Wait, is this a bot, too?
Yeah, this is a bot.
I think this guy's over here, so...
No, please.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to shoot you.
Oh, yeah.
He is here.
Please.
Oh, where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Over here.
I got him.
Broke guy 1093.
Oh, my God.
He has so many stuff.
What?
He has a laser rifle.
He has a shield bubble.
You know what he doesn't have?
He doesn't have beaches.
Oh, that's true.
He plays Fortnite.
Yeah, he does have a giant candy cane body.
That's freaking true.
Oops, that's me.
Is that the boss?
I don't know.
Here, I'm gonna give you a...
Nice.
I wasn't gonna do anything with it, but nice.
Oh, you can tell me, like, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where were they?
Oh, there she is.
Wait, what do you get from there?
Oh, you get unlimited ammo.
Yeah, you can get it.
Yeah, get that shit.
Okay, you get that, then.
No, no, no, you get that.
You get that.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, okay.
Oh, what's this?
That's an explosive crossbow.
Is it good?
It's pretty good, yeah.
It, like, messes up cars.
Oh, look at this guy.
This guy here.
Oh, like this car?
What the fuck?
That's not you!
I was like, I was like, yay, and I turned around.
I was like, who's that?
I'm so sad.
It put the thing in the wrong eye of sight for me.
I was like, I didn't realize that.
I didn't realize we got fucking ran out.
I was just like, look at that car.
I was like, oh, hey, there's a car.
There's some guy showing up beside me.
I was so...
There's a guy showing up beside me the moment you said that.
I thought that was you.
I was like, there's a guy...
Yeah, and he's like, get out of nowhere!
Yeah, you thought you get no audio in Apex only?
Oh, there's no audio in here, too.
Four nights a week, you can have it.
The music made it so I couldn't hear.
I couldn't.
I just saw a car.
I thought you were just casually picking up stuff.
Yeah, it's like, yay!
Oh, the car is here!
There's somebody like a dude right next to you.
I'll be like, oh, I'll use this over the car.
Oh, my god.
That was so funny.
You gotta run the wolf skin on the last game.
I'm running the wolf skin?
Yeah, for good luck, because it's your main.
And then I'll run the very first skin I ever bought.
Are you gonna be the candy cane?
Yeah, the candy cane.
The very first skin.
Oh, candy cane and wolf?
Yeah.
Oh, my god, it's Billie Eilish.
Billie Eilish?
Look at her go.
She's going, look at her.
Yay!
I'm having a bad day, Billie.
Can you, like, cheer me up?
Oh, look, Billie's making a rape for us.
Oh, thank you, Billie.
I've been getting bullied by Fortnite pros all day.
Last two days.
Today's my rest week.
And then I'm getting bullied by grown men.
I was gonna say, what are you getting bullied by next week?
What's the next thing you're gonna get bullied by?
Are you gonna get bullied by Minecraft players next week?
Oh, I was.
I did have that happen, too.
Wait, did you actually?
Yeah, I was in the Minecraft Twitch Rivals and I got bullied by Minecraft players.
Wait, what happened?
Wait, all of a sudden, I got bullied.
Okay.
Let's go to the log place again.
We got to shoot our guns.
We had action.
Literally became an anime character that featured candy canes.
Ooh!
That sounds fun.
Did we get Isekai into another freaking candy cane?
I don't know what that means.
It's so loud in here.
It is.
How am I supposed to figure out what's going on when I can't even hear my own footsteps?
That's a secret.
We're not supposed to.
No!
What's the point?
Oh my gosh, we are spam crouching.
Whoa, what a gamer.
Oh, they had a crown.
You wanna rob me?
No, I took somebody's cash.
Ooh!
I got Magneto powers!
Yeah!
Where are they?
Throw big balls at them.
Where?
I'm ready.
I think they're on the other side.
Oh, they're over here?
I don't have any shields, but I'm ready.
Oh, I have a shield.
Oh wait, no, it's okay.
I found, I found, let it rain.
Let it rain.
Woo!
We are the champions.
We are...
Okay, it's done.
I'm gonna jump through the ring.
Okay, me too.
Woo!
Wait, oh.
It's a Christmas skin!
Get over here.
Get over here!
That's fucking right.
You're fucking on them.
That's fucking, don't make me pull this off.
How did you do that?
Where is he?
Oh, nice.
Oh, they're dead!
Oh my fucking god.
Nice.
I didn't even get shot at.
Yo, you're insane.
How'd you do that?
Pure anger.
These guys aren't froze.
They're probably 12 year olds who are off of school now.
They're probably, they're probably actually kids.
Thank god.
Thank god there's actual children playing this game so I can feel something.
Oh, there's a ship!
Oh no, that's not a ship.
God damn it.
I thought that was gonna be a ship.
I was gonna be like, yay, it was a launch pad.
Yeah, you're right.
I haven't seen any ships.
Where are the ships at?
Yeah, me too.
I haven't seen any.
Where's that guy I killed?
I think, did he die above?
I think he killed him above.
Yeah, I killed him above, yes.
Oh shit, I put two, I put all the launch pads.
Pew!
Oh, is that bear's shotgun?
Oh, never mind.
My weapons suck.
Alright, warrior.
Is this a shotgun too?
It is.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh, shield EMP.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, that's already looted.
You didn't spawn the boss.
Do you want the medallion again?
Nah, that's fine.
After what happened to me there, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright, let me see if I can get her to spawn.
I'm gonna grab the medallion for us.
Oh, what?
I'm gonna waste this medkit.
Oh wait, no, there's a fucking cactus there.
Never mind.
Yeah, see, you're already learning all these things that other players don't even know yet.
Yeah!
I think everybody knows already.
I don't think I'm...
Let's see.
Ooh, all arounder.
I want that.
I want an all-rounder.
I don't want to go around the onion ring here.
What the hell?
Where's the fucking cactus?
Oh, there's a car here.
Give me that cactus.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, there's a car there.
Yeah, there's a vehicle here.
Fucking... Get away!
Get away!
I'm with you.
Oh shit, we're magnealing!
Oh shit!
I might be dead though.
Oh, you're good, you're good.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm getting this cactus.
Yeah, yeah, get the cactus.
Oh my god.
How do I float with it?
Oh, you gotta...
You have to just have it equipped.
No!
Come back here!
Get back here!
You smell!
Yeah!
Let's fucking go!
Get the shit on!
They got shit on!
Okay.
And they're fucking dead.
Fucking dead.
Yeah!
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Yay!
Yeah, get shit on!
How are you dancing with it on?
Oh, there you go.
Get shit on!
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
These guys are probably also like 12-year-olds too.
These guys never fucking fought real pro players.
What?
Oh, what's that?
Wait, no, never mind.
I thought that was the ship.
I think it's treasure.
No, that's the buried treasure.
Oh, let's see.
Where does it go to?
Oh, it's so far.
I don't want to go to that.
Yeah, that's why it got thrown away.
That's why children are so toxic.
They need to learn about the real world.
Yeah.
Their hopes and spirits have to be crushed.
Eventually.
Like, you're welcome.
I wish my spirits were crushed when I was a child.
That's what I'm saying!
If you don't get crushed as a child, you're gonna get crushed at some point.
Yeah.
Then I know.
I know I'm not special.
They need to know they're not special.
Yeah, let them know while they're young.
Yeah, exactly.
Fucking living that delusion when your parents are like, you're special.
Not everybody's special.
Especially you, child.
Oh, I knocked her down there.
It's the boss lady.
Where is she?
There she is.
Boom!
Oh shit, I'm floating.
Get shit on, nerd!
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Wait, I'm getting shot.
I'm getting shot by real people!
Real people!
Oh, is that AI?
Oh, sorry.
I couldn't tell.
I can't tell these days.
What's real and what's not.
They all look the same.
You're all AI to me!
You're all AI!
Wait,
what the hell is this?
Let it rain!
Let it rain on me!
Let the rain fall down!
Oh, you wanna get the boss car?
Oh, there's a boss?
Is that the car that like...
The one that destroys everyone?
Yeah, the one where they...
Yeah, the one that they destroyed everybody with and got cars back.
You're gonna literally be the best gunner in this thing.
Oh my gosh, the one where...
Alright, no, that wasn't it.
Oh, they must have modded it then.
Yeah, they had a different one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go fuck shit up!
Yeah, let's go fuck shit up.
Let's ruin these people's time.
Look at these guys here.
Look at these dudes.
Yeah, they tried you.
That's fucking right.
You think like this is gonna help you?
Wait, what the fuck?
What did we get hit by?
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god, they both have fists?
Fucking nerds.
You think your movement is cute?
Where did they go?
I think they're over here.
Wait, wait.
What?
They're in the trees?
You think I care about your trees?
Where did they go?
They're like over here.
Are they in another tree?
They're literally in another tree.
Oh, there's a guy over here.
I see him.
Bro, what the fuck?
It's so hard to aim with this.
Where is he?
I see you.
You don't have the fists forever.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe you do.
Maybe you do.
They just keep fisting away.
Wait, they rez?
They rez?
I think someone just rez, yeah.
Where?
I think, like right next to us.
Wait, why is it pink?
Yeah, you see that?
Oh, there he is, yeah.
Is that Ariana Grande?
Everybody has fists?
What's wrong with you?
Get back here, Ariana Grande.
Just fucking run her over.
Fuck this.
Just run her over.
Fucking nerds.
Oh my god, shoot a gun.
Welcome to Fortnite.
Shoot a fucking real gun.
This is not melee.
Go to Evo.
Evo is literally right now.
Go to fucking Evo.
They're all just running and not shooting their weapons.
Yeah.
Wait.
I think they're fighting over here.
There's so much death here.
Oh my god, there's so many dead bodies, yeah.
Oh wait, are they on the ship?
No, they're not.
Let's go chase that one.
That's an NPC, right?
Yeah.
Oh, that's Barbossa.
Oh, Barbossa!
Barbossa!
Why are you bringing a sword to a gunfight?
Yeah, you fucking bitch.
Fucking idiot.
Barbossa can fly.
Yeah, I get shit on Barbossa.
Yeah.
Where the fuck are people?
There's still 17 people left.
How is the game not ended yet?
How is game 6 not ready?
They're probably close to the last zone.
Oh my god.
Maybe another few minutes?
Oh!
Wait, I can see.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna tap out real quick.
Oh god.
Yeah, they're literally still on last zone.
Oh my god, they're still going?
Jesus Christ.
They're literally going.
Alright.
The longest Fortnite match ever.
Where are they?
Oh, they have the magneto gloves!
Oh, wait.
What is he doing?
Are they gonna magneto glove us?
Yup.
Oh, they are.
Oh!
Shit!
Wait, they're so good with this!
Where are they?
Oh!
Bro, he's...
He's different!
Oh my god, this guy's a gamer.
Oh, of course they have the freaking...
They have the medallion or whatever.
Wait, the medallion?
Keep throwing game, please!
Oh my god, I'm dead.
What medallion do they have?
They have the infinite nitro one.
It's always the one that I die to.
All the time.
Bro, that guy...
That guy's been playing Fortnite for a while.
I can tell.
Literally fucking hitting me hitting me with magneto style.
That shit was crazy.
That shit was actually crazy.
I think...
He's on your body right now.
Oh, I forgot I have this freaking...
Oh, the medallion.
Oh, you also have the medallion, don't you?
Yeah, I have the medallion, so they're probably just gonna keep chasing me.
Unless...
Like, we're good.
We're good.
I can heal.
Oh, nice.
Wait, they're like down here.
Maybe I'll get your card.
Guys, we're not gonna miss game 6 because they're literally still playing.
They've been playing for 20 years.
Ew, look at this guy.
What the fuck?
You're dead.
Oh my god.
I think they might run to you after that.
What is happening?
I don't even care.
I have to die.
What the fuck is this movement?
Don't die.
Game 6 is still not starting.
Oh shit, really?
You gotta be alive.
Oh wait, I see him.
Game?
Can you like, do the thing?
Oh my god, you're crazy.
You're so dead for that.
I'm so dead?
Oh, they're running.
Kill him.
At least...
At least kill him.
That's all I care.
Yeah, he's dead.
Fuck you.
Wait, you can grab my card.
Okay, I guess not.
Oh, you should not grab my card.
Nah, we live this.
You have practice living.
Practice for game 6.
You have practice for game 6.
Oh my god, he's so mad.
Wait, is he still chasing you?
Holy shit.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did he go?
He's gone.
Oh, he stopped.
He stopped.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is how... what's happening.
Guys, this is like, basically how Fortnite is supposed to be played apparently now.
It's not about you using your guns anymore.
No, what's with your gun?
That's so like, last year.
Yeah, like, who the fuck shoots their guns?
Do you want me to revive you?
Oh, I didn't even get your card.
No, it's fine.
I need you to practice the solo runs.
No!
Dorio, you need to do this for pho.
I need to eat pho.
Okay, the pho is gonna be my one thing.
Dorio, if we are not above Jay, I'm not getting pho.
No, don't tell me that.
I'm not getting pho.
I'm working for the pho.
We're doing it.
I'm gonna go for that guy.
Which one?
The dude who killed you.
Oh shit, yeah.
Wait, oh?
Yeah, game 5 is over, but we haven't got the code yet.
We're just waiting for the code.
Holy shit.
They should be able to respawn their buddy though.
Yeah, there he is.
There's orange kid.
I think he went to get his buddy too.
Did he?
I don't think he got him yet, did he?
Well, they've been there for a while now.
Oh, there he is.
There he is again.
What's this guy doing?
You have unlimited nitro, dude.
Whoa.
I don't think, did he res them?
I don't know.
I mean, there's still the res car.
He could be here if he res.
Oh my god, they're here?
Oh.
What the fuck is going on?
Why do I...
I don't even know what Fortnite is anymore.
Oh my god.
This guy is just running the whole time.
Magneto versus Magneto.
I don't get pushed in the back.
Oh, the other medallions are...
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm gone.
Well, they know you're a medallion too.
This is a Dragon Ball Z battle.
It is.
This is why nobody takes Fortnite competitive seriously anymore.
This is why I definitely do not play competitively.
The thing is, Battle Royale is already really difficult.
Because of RNG.
And then you factor in all these ridiculous mechanics.
It's so hard to balance competitively.
For Battle Royale.
Because it's just full on RNG.
On who has the better loot.
Fortnite is so...
It also has a very bad tick rate.
Because the netcode is really bad.
And then you factor in build mode.
Yeah.
And it's just extra bad.
Oh, is he going to give you stuff?
Oh, yes he is.
Yeah!
Oh, and you got... whoa!
I got stuff.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Yeah.
Are they fighting?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Free reboot.
I think they're going to come over here in a sec.
Oh!
Wait, someone died.
Oh yeah, they change the rules all the time.
Yeah, I agree.
Oh, that confession guy is the one that killed me.
Oh, the confession guy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's him.
That's the purple... the orange shirt guy.
Wait, are they on you?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I got shot by those... by somebody there.
Heading to you.
Wait, this guy is dead.
Oh, that's not confession though.
Oh!
Oh my god!
What's going on?
What happened in there?
I knocked on there.
Boom!
No!
Wait, did I kill him?
I killed someone inside there.
Oh, wait, there's a different team.
What?
I smashed them too!
What do you mean?
I punched so much!
All I did was punch!
How did he live through that?
Oh, I got 180'd by a shotgun.
RIP.
He headshot me.
That makes sense actually.
You got fortnited.
I got fortnited, that's for sure.
I definitely got fortnited.
So now we're on the last match, right?
Yeah, yeah.
They banned SMGs and pistols.
Yeah, every pistol SMG is banned now.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see the rules, yeah.
Okay, we got lobby code too.
Okay, I'm gonna enter the code.
Alright.
I got the code entered.
I'm playing the very first skin I ever bought.
What if I want to be a candy king too?
No.
We need your main.
I play my very first skin and you play your...
We need good luck.
Good luck everybody.
Good luck.
Please, we need it guys.
Give us your energy.
Raise your hand up chat.
For Faw.
Yeah, this is Faw on the line.
Guys, Faw.
Oh my god, John Wick is in the store.
Wait, John Wick's in the store?
Oh my god.
I need to get John Wick, okay.
I completely forgot they refreshed the store.
Oh my god.
Oh, they got the creepy alien guy.
Creepy alien guy?
What?
Yeah, Zorgaton?
Wait, I don't think I have that.
Zorgaton?
I don't even know how to say his name.
I think it's like...
I think it's like for you only.
Oh no, I see it, I see it.
Leviathan and Zorgaton.
Oh yeah, the ugly guys.
Yeah, the ugly dudes.
Alright, I gotta buy John Wick.
Fuck, I don't have V-Bucks.
God damn it.
Okay, how many players?
36.
Okay, I can spend money.
No, we're good.
You can definitely get it.
Yeah, give me a sec, guys.
I'm not gonna be...
I'm gonna be John Wick instead of my first skin.
This is much more important.
This is much more important, guys.
Okay, purchase.
Yay!
Oh, loading my order?
Did you get it?
I got epic rewards.
And then...
I'm paying for it?
Place order?
I need to log into my Paypal.
Give me a sec, guys.
This is very...
Guys, you don't understand.
Oh my god, did you so...
Guys, I can't buy it yet.
Sorry.
You can't get it?
Cause I have to order for...
I don't remember my Paypal login right now.
I'm too lazy.
I would gift it to you, but like...
I can't gift it to you unless we're friends for two days.
We have to be friends.
Two more days?
No, it's like one more day, but like...
One more day?
Yeah, it's two days until you can actually give someone something.
I can't believe it.
I can't be John Wick on the last game.
No!
Guys...
You can be John Cena, though.
No, it's not the same.
John Wick is not John Cena, confirmed.
It's not the same.
Okay, in some alternate universe, he is definitely John Wick.
That's true.
Just buff John Cena running around in a suit.
Suit and tie.
This is it, guys.
This is it.
I can't get over the fact that this is just like a giant candy cane and a werewolf.
The dream team.
This is the dream team right here.
Right there.
Oh, you're on the wrong side.
Right here.
Oh, yeah, that's me.
No, it's okay.
I'm on the right side on my screen.
That's all that matters.
I'm on the right side.
It's correct here.
This is it.
Okay, are we ready?
This is the moment that we play for the fuck.
Yeah, this is it.
Jay is above you guys.
I cannot get far if we're not above Jay.
Are we still 19?
I think.
No, Jay got above us though.
We're 19 though?
Oh, wait, Jay got above us?
Wait, who's 20th?
Where the fuck was 20th then?
Uh...
Let's see, where...
Oh, they're showing 10?
Wait, what?
No, we're 19.
Yeah, then who's 20th?
20th is still Jay.
Yo, let's fucking go!
Yo!
Yeah, they got the two points and died.
Yo, wait.
Guys, okay, Dory, you need to get points.
So, you need to...
You need to get points.
Where is Autumn and them landing?
Oh, they're landing there?
I'm just trying to think, like, hmm...
Where can we get some...
Where can we get some points?
Okay, are we gonna do our spot though?
Like, uh, below Nitro Dome?
Or should we go to the...
I don't know.
I think we go below Nitro Dome, right?
Or no?
In the last game?
Well, we have to... Well, it's safe zone.
So, we have to get a spot.
Yeah, we have to get a spot and then...
Oh, you want to do Grim Gate then?
Yeah, Grim Gate and then we have to find a spot to, like, be safe.
Like, right after.
So, we can't loiter.
We shouldn't loiter.
Alright, so let's just loot it as fast as we can.
Oh, it's the banana dance!
That's the banana dance!
This song?
Yeah!
It's like a Fortnite meme.
No, it's a marshmallow.
It's the banana dance!
I saw the fucking YouTube short!
Wait, what?
Where is it?
I'm no longer calling him Marshmallow.
I'm just gonna call him Banana Man.
Oh, did you drop already?
I'm not supposed to drop?
Uh, I mean...
Yeah, you'll still make it.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
You can just glide down slowly.
You can glide down slowly.
I got confused.
Alright, we are good.
Why is there so many people landing here now?
We got, like, three people.
There's more than three!
It's like four!
There's, like, condoms here too.
Yeah!
I'm so confused!
It's safe zone, right?
Yeah, it's safe zone right now.
I'm just watching him, like, run around and be a gremlin.
Like, why?
Can you, like, jump through?
There we go.
We're really, like, fucked up, guys.
Are they gonna follow us?
Is that what they're gonna do?
I don't know, actually.
Are they, like, gonna follow us and try to farm us?
They're probably just trying to, like, loot everything as fast as they can so they can grief us.
I think.
Oh, wait, we can't have thunderbursts, right?
Uh, we can have...
I don't remember.
Oh, yeah, no, uh...
Oh, wait, so shotgun?
Okay.
Should we leave?
I feel like we don't have loot anymore.
Um...
We can go on the outside.
We're gonna hit these.
We're not comfortable down here.
No thunderburst, right?
Yeah, no thunderburst.
We can run a shotgun, though.
Okay, let's hit this.
And then let's hit these.
We should leave.
I don't feel...
And then take this.
Oh, Nuka Cola.
And then let's try to go up here.
Let's go up here.
Okay.
I'm gonna start going.
Ooh!
I have two shockwaves.
I can give you one just in case.
Unless you don't want that.
It's fine.
No, you got it!
I have nitro!
Wait, someone landed up here.
What?
Okay, I guess we're going over here?
I think everybody's just landing in areas where they can get kills.
Yeah.
Alright, well, let's just go this way then.
We have a minute to be safe, though.
So we should hurry.
We are, uh...
Oh my god, it's looted!
That's so safe, Doryu.
48 seconds.
Yeah, so we have a shotgun.
And that's it.
Is stealthy spotter enforcer okay or no?
Uh, yeah.
That's fine.
You can grab that.
Okay, I got an enforcer.
Oh, let's hit you up all the way.
Oh no, this is already taken.
Dang.
Well, I mean...
25 seconds.
Where do we go?
Let's keep going this way.
Are you sure we're safe?
Uh, it's safer than going south.
That's for sure.
I think if we go south, we're gonna get kinda screwed.
Yeah, I feel like people are...
Oh, 9 seconds.
This is scary.
Dang.
We literally have...
nothing.
Uh oh.
We have to be somewhere safe.
We could go...
to restored reels.
Or we could go...
Wanna hide in this bush right here?
Sure, let's just...
You know what?
Yeah, fuck it.
Fuck it.
Wait, I wanna loot the top of this hill real quick.
I'm gonna be in this bush.
You go loot that.
Okay, okay, okay.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll be the test subject up here.
Whatever makes I feel safe in my bush.
Nobody will know.
Yeah, I got nitros.
So that's good.
I don't feel safe in this dangerous world of fortniters.
Uh, okay, so...
I got like some...
I wanna come down.
The bush life.
I swear to god, if you bring somebody over...
Crazy, I ban a weapon, but it still spawns on the map?
I swear to god, Doryu, if you bring a fucking uninvited visitor in the bush, I swear to god...
You have a gun?
Yeah, I do.
I got the...
Selfie spotty.
Oh, you got the selfie?
Yeah, that's not bad, right?
No, that's not bad.
Uh, I'm looking at the list right now.
It's only like SMGs, and then hand cannon, pistol, and a flintlock?
Nobody's dead.
Why is this always the last game where nobody's dead?
Right?
I wanna look at your pickle, Rick.
I'm gonna get your pickle.
Oh, it's cause it's 19...
Oh, the storm starts in 16 seconds.
Okay, that's...
Yeah, that's why.
They start...
They start fighting in 16 seconds.
Or 10 seconds.
Okay, if someone shoots us there, that means somebody has, like, like, has been, like, following us.
You know what's funny about this bush, though?
What?
Is that this bush, even though it's like a random ass, like, place to hide, it's very notorious for just randomly getting ran through.
Oh, I don't like that.
Why did you tell me that now?
This is how I'm gonna feel if Doki doesn't get her pho.
Guys, I need my pho.
Wait!
Apply!
What?
Apply got eliminated!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god!
We got less!
Doki, we can die happily now.
Yeah, I can naturally go fucking eat now.
I can literally just leave this game.
Yes!
Oh my fucking god.
Look, this is not...
It was meant to be.
We're not being cowards right now.
Look, I need to eat, guys.
No, listen, we got $125 on the line here, okay?
Yeah!
Yeah, exactly.
What are the other teams gonna get?
Not $125?
Oh my god, it's coming by.
I'm gonna nitro us if they jump in here.
BT doves.
Oh, they ran away.
But there are gunfights to our revenge.
Right.
Or here.
We might be able to catch someone that goes by us.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
They're like kinda jumping around.
Wait, where's the other medallion?
Okay, one, two, and then...
I don't even see the third one.
Only two medallions.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I see them.
He's just running around.
I wanna shoot them so bad, Doki.
There's a medallion right next to us.
I think they're gonna fuck us up.
Yeah, we don't.
I think the medallion is gonna fuck us up if we didn't get any closer.
What do you think the commentators are saying?
Do you think they're watching us just like...
They're just like, they don't understand.
This is for pho.
Like, they don't understand.
Like, literally, we just got pho because of this.
Like, we fucking won.
Like, you know what?
I'll order you some pho.
No, actually, no.
You gotta go there and eat pho.
Ordering pho is not good as eating ass quiz.
I actually have a really, really good phubble at home.
But, like, you're right.
It never hits the same, though.
Yeah, it never hits the same going out.
Yeah.
FIFA.
I can't believe we ended up getting the pho.
I can't believe it.
They literally died for it.
I'm so glad.
I'm so happy.
Yeah.
Thank you.
At least we're better than Overwatch players.
This is true.
Yeah.
We were technically above them.
I mean, it doesn't take much.
But, like, yeah.
I can say it.
I used to be an Overwatch player.
All the Overwatchers are gonna be like, yeah, but what peak are you, Doki?
What's your peak?
4500.
Shiiiit!
Yeah, that's right.
And they're gonna be like, okay, but what was your role then?
Support.
And then you're going to be like, okay, what support were you?
Lucio, Ana, Zen.
Yeah, Lucio's Giga.
Yeah, Lucio was my one trick.
And Ana's extra Giga.
Yeah, Lucio used to be my one trick.
And then, like, they gutted Lucio.
R.I.P.
Lucio.
Wait, okay, we have to move.
We have like 30 seconds though, so we're gonna go...
There is a bush?
I think that's like right here?
Oh my god, the next bush.
There's a bush over here.
Okay, nice.
Our next home.
Our next house.
This is Fortnite gameplay.
How is only two people dead in this fucking...
J3 and apply?
Yeah guys, I was in the Overwatch community when J3 used to be Jesus3.
Like, that's his old name.
Did he really?
Yeah, his old name was Jesus3.
And then he changed into J3 when he got partnered.
Or no, after he got partnered.
No, it was a while back.
Wait, why did he un-Jesus?
I don't fucking know.
I think he realized maybe having your name as Jesus for your Twitch name might not be the best idea.
He could be Jesus though.
Oh, that's true.
If he has an accent.
I don't think he's like...
I don't think he's a Jesus person.
Does he look like he walks on water?
Yeah, he does look like he walks on water.
Alright, let's go now.
Oh my god, our bush!
Our bush!
Our lovely bush!
I have nitro as well.
Okay, okay.
Whenever the nitro runs out, only pop it when you're out in the open with no cover.
Otherwise, don't even use it.
I think we should be good here.
Do you think they saw us run to that bush?
No, never.
Do you think they saw us?
I'm in the bush right now.
I think we're gonna be okay.
See?
Oh, we're good!
We're good!
Come here, Doki!
It's nice and cozy in here!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, bush time!
We're the bush people!
The Bushmen!
I mean, we're more of a bush candy cane.
And a bushman.
I told you, the skins are good luck!
The safety bush.
Yo, one of the purses died.
Think about it.
Oh, thank god, that's not us.
We're definitely not dying any time soon.
Yeah, exactly.
The bush is safe.
Mr. Beast would love this.
You think Mr. Beast lives in a million dollar bush?
Oh, a hundred percent.
If he could, he would.
Like, what do you do with all that money?
You have to honestly ask yourself.
Honestly, what would you do with all that money?
I don't know, cure the fucking blind?
Yeah.
Literally, what he does.
He has so much money.
He just does all these elaborate stuff.
Is there a way to...
Like, what else would you do?
Can you just pay everyone the same in this journey?
What's that sound?
Oh, that's the island that's spawning.
Oh, okay.
That scared the shit out of me.
We could go up to the island.
You wanna go up to the island?
I feel like everybody's going to go to the island for better loot, right?
Pretty much, yeah.
So what we could do then...
Is we could go...
Where's the nearest bush?
I think the next bush is right over here.
That's so far.
Oh yeah, they're fighting here.
There's a team literally right there.
Yeah, I mean, I would...
I assume they would all wanna go there.
Wait, do you hear that?
Yeah, they're like right here on the red ping.
Yeah, I heard it.
What's that?
They're gonna go up now, I think?
Should we leave?
I think they're just gonna glove up.
Yeah, they're gloving up right now.
Okay, here, follow me.
Follow me.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Like, I don't think we should be close to that.
Hearing all those sounds...
I just do not feel comfortable.
Okay, let's pop a...
Oh, I'm trying to think.
There should be a team over there.
Okay, they have... Keep following me.
Keep following me.
I'm gonna nitrous.
And then just keep sprinting.
Okay, I'm sprinting.
I'm sprinting.
We're gonna go...
We can go to this house, actually.
Wouldn't those people up top there would cross here?
They would, but we can chill at the very, very top here.
Inside?
Oh yeah, you are.
Okay, cool.
Come up here.
Nice.
Now we're cozy.
Yeah.
All we're doing is we're playing OG...
OG Apex Rotates.
Where it was just...
Yeah, that was the island.
The island disappeared, right?
No, it stays up there, but that sound means that they captured the flag.
Oh, I can't believe it.
We upgraded our house.
We're vibing.
We pushed the house.
Guys!
We made it!
We made it, guys!
Does your head poke through there?
Okay, it doesn't.
Guys, we made it.
Okay, whatever you do, don't, like, even move while crouched, because they can hear it.
It just doesn't show an audio indicator.
Oh, okay.
If they're, like, coming up to us, just, like, let them...
Alright, my hands are off the fucking mouse and keyboard.
Honestly, same.
I'm literally just, like, sitting here.
My god, it's a free MrBeast house!
He gave us a house!
MrBeast!
Thank you!
MrBeast, you're the best!
Except my boyfriend never.
Oh my god!
We did it!
I think on the next zone close, I feel like it's gonna keep pulling south.
Because usually the Fortnite zones, they always go to the opposite side.
Oh, they spawned somebody back.
It was back to 37.
Wait, I thought it was at 37.
No, it was, like, 36.
Oh!
Oh, we're good!
Okay.
That bush is out of zone.
We can go to this bush.
Or I think this one.
We can go this one.
Wanna go that one?
Are we gonna make it?
Wait, somebody's gliding above us.
We're gonna chill, we're gonna chill.
Oh, I'm scared.
So many people gliding above us.
I have a med kit.
Chill here.
I'm gonna inspect real quick.
Wait, there's a shockwave here?
Let me check that.
Uh, Joki, you can come out.
Come out, come out.
We're gonna run to that bush.
Okay, we're running to the bush.
Oh, wait, no?
Where are they gloving to?
Okay, we're gonna yoink this.
Ooh, that's our bunker now.
We're gonna chill here.
We're gonna chill in here.
Is that in?
Yeah, it's in.
Our house now, yoink.
Yoink.
Thank you, MrBeast.
Oh, somebody's next to us.
We're gonna do this.
113 on them?
Where is he?
They're right next to us.
Cracked.
Seven flush.
Got him?
Oh, let's go, Joki!
Where's the other one at?
Nuka-Cola, Nuka-Cola.
Nuka-Cola.
I'm holding it.
Did you get him?
No, not yet, not yet.
I'm gonna do this.
I don't know where you got shot at.
Oh, you got him.
You got him.
Yeah, I got him.
Okay, I can get the gloves.
And I'm getting this.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Do you want shockwaves?
No, I mean, I could hold it.
Okay, I'm gonna chill here for a sec.
And I'm just gonna drop...
I'm gonna drop this one.
Whoa.
Where's his teammate go?
Oh, what?
This guy had insane stuff.
I mean...
I assume so.
He was jumping everywhere.
We're in zone.
Yeah, we're in zone, yeah.
Hey!
Yay!
Alright, we're chillin' here.
Okay, so we got one kill.
I'm proud of us.
I'm gonna drop those so you have movement.
Here's a portal bunker.
Okay, I'll...
Actually, do you want the shockwaves or no?
They grab the card.
They're back here.
42?
36?
Oh my god.
I think they're gonna try to go for a revive at some point.
But...
I'm gonna drop heals here.
Alright.
I'm gonna leave them inside here.
I'm gonna carry the bunk just in case.
Thank god there's no lobos here.
Thank god.
I think they're gonna try to go for a rose.
Oh, look!
We're not dead last!
Wait, the house is back.
The one thing I'm afraid of is...
Oh, the island's gonna be...
Kinda in.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh?
41?
I actually don't have too much ammo.
Oh, me too.
I realize.
We should conserve it, right?
Yeah, I'm gonna stop doing damage.
I'm chillin'.
People are shit over here.
There's gonna be a team up top here.
Just be very careful.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Let me just chill here.
Oh my god, there's fucking three medallions next to us.
Right?
We're so popular.
Oh my god.
Hey guys.
Oh, they're fighting up there now.
Yeah.
Oh, zone is not near us.
This is gonna be a little awkward.
Can I shoot through these holes?
Can I shoot the hole through the holes?
I'm pretty sure you can.
Can you?
Okay, that's cool.
Just like Apex.
These guys zoom.
Where are my bullets going?
I swear I see them hitting this guy.
I don't know, but I'm just looking through these holes.
I literally have...
Oh, this is like...
Heat vision.
Which one?
Oh, you're talking about the thermal?
Yeah, yeah, thermal.
Okay, so what we're gonna have to do is we're gonna try to get to...
Is this it?
That's not it.
Okay.
People right here?
So what I'm thinking we do...
Is we're gonna try to get to that rock.
And we're gonna make a...
Bunker?
Yeah.
Nitroly or what?
Oh yeah, you have nitro still, yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
I can nitro us.
Oh, what the?
Oh yeah, which one?
Nitro?
Nitro now?
Okay, let's go.
Follow me.
We're gonna go to the side?
Oh, shit!
We go up here?
What?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna do this here.
I can't!
I got bugged!
Oh no!
I'm looking back for you!
No!
I got bugged!
Oh!
I couldn't climb up!
Do not do anything!
Just live!
Remember what we said!
I'm living!
I got bugged!
I couldn't climb up!
No!
Just live!
Do you remember what I said?
All you have to do is live!
Just live!
Okay, I'm gonna break this.
I hope I don't die for this.
There we go.
Okay.
I had...
stuff!
I don't know what I had, but...
I want that stuff so bad.
I don't know if I can get to it, though.
No, it's okay.
Just live!
Oh my god, we're not dead last!
We're not dead last!
Oh my god, this is the best we've ever done!
This is the best we've ever done!
Just stay there!
I might die in this routine, though.
I have, like, such little... I have shock!
I have one shock thing.
Oh, you do?
Okay.
I think I'm gonna eat Storm.
Oh, I think they took it.
Yeah, they definitely grabbed it.
Like, it's my shock thing now.
Yeah, I have a shield bubble, too.
That's why.
Oh my god.
Can you afford to eat it?
Oh, I see someone there.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
That's four, but okay!
Steal his house!
We're good!
You stole his house!
Oh my god, there's a ship!
That's what we wanted to do earlier!
Remember!
He had two ships!
I'm gonna go over here?
I don't know what's happening.
He has two ships!
That's what's gonna happen.
I'm so dead!
He had two ships!
That's crazy!
Damn.
Oh, I got creeped by a solo!
Oh my god!
I should have probably turned to just shoot them.
Wait, what?
This guy killed them all?
Yeah, this guy killed them!
Holy shit!
We got twelve!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go!
I knew this record!
That's the best we've ever done!
And that's all it matters!
Let's fucking go!
You know what's funny?
We had scuffed loot that game too!
And we still lived longer than we've been!
We got a kill as well!
Yeah, we got a kill!
We got a twelve life!
And we get far life!
Like, oh my god, we get far as well!
Like, everything's going up for us!
Oh, wait, you have to be tenth?
You have to be tenth to get three points.
Wait, really?
Boo!
Yeah, tenth to twentieth is all one point.
Twelve teams in the last ring.
That's crazy.
Hey, imagine playing a game competitively with all these bugs.
Oh my god.
Like, I got stuck in the climb.
Yeah, was your character teleporting?
They kept pushing me back.
I had that bug happening too when I was trying to do it.
I got super lucky when I jumped around.
But otherwise, I was like...
I was afraid I was going to suffer the same death too.
Yeah, I was like, nooo!
I got stuck!
I couldn't go back!
Yo, Porta Bunker City?
Oh my god, this is my favorite.
There's so many Porta Bunkers.
Oh my god, how are they going to get out?
Is Mr. Beast here?
Oh my god, all I hear is just gunshots and Porta...
Oh my god, look at all these free real estates!
Oh my god!
Look at all these free real estates though!
I like how Zero Build turns into the same exact thing that Build Mode does.
Because there's so many bunkers.
Oh my god, he's 1 HP.
He literally got hit one...
Oh, there he goes.
Where's his teammate?
Oh, there he is.
His teammate is just flying up.
Can't hit him if he's just flying!
And he died to zone.
He died to zone!
Oh my god!
I watched a guy just stay in the...
You know, like Valkalp?
He did that, and then he fucking...
He just stayed in the zone and died to zone.
Oh my god, I wonder if anyone...
No one has Shockwave and done the Magneto Gloves up.
This guy lost that.
Oh shit.
I think it's like...
Oh, it's too late.
It's 3 teams, so it's a solo and 2 duos.
Yeah.
Ugh.
Oh, now it's a solo and 2 duos.
Wait, no, 1v1?
Yeah, it's a 1v1.
Oh my god, 12 HP.
12 HP!
He died to zone.
It would be so funny.
Oh my god!
Dude, this guy panicked.
Oh no!
God damn it!
It would have been so funny though if he died to zone.
Rest in pupper.
Guys, we're getting... we're already winning, guys.
Wait, that was our biggest game!
Yeah!
Well, to be fair, we didn't get...
extra points for it because you don't get points until 10th place.
Hey, Noah, morally, we got 12.
Morally, we did better.
Yeah, we did better.
We're getting far, guys!
I'm getting far tonight.
Let's go!
We're all getting far!
Let's fucking go!
Okay, do you feel following vehicle mod is too weak?
Yes, too fucking weak.
Wait, for which one?
Oh, I got the we want your feedback.
Yeah, tell us how good that match was.
On a scale of 1 to 10.
I voted all ones, so they'll buff it.
It was like, what's your feeling about this particular gun?
And I said it sucked.
So that means they're gonna buff it because of my input.
Guys, guys, guys.
We got... we got Doki feedback.
We gotta do it.
Gotta do it.
Alright.
I wanna see the final placements.
I think we got, like, 19th, right?
I think.
18th or 19th.
We got either 18th or 19th because we're definitely not 20th.
Top 20th!
Let's go!
We're definitely not 20th.
Doki, I'm proud of us.
That's all that matters.
Me too.
I'm proud of us.
Our vibes were more immaculate than every other team.
Yeah, we had the best vibes and we weren't last.
And who... what other team runs a candy cane?
We literally beat Overwatch players.
Like, Overwatch pros.
Like...
Yeah, what are they...
What are they diamonding?
What are they trying to be masters of?
You know what's funny?
They're watching the...
They're watching, like, Overwatch gameplay now.
They're, like, so checked.
They're not... they're not...
Are they really?
They've already swapped to Overwatch.
Wait, what was their name again?
Just J3?
J3, yeah.
He's doing a... he's doing, like, watching the tournament.
I thought it was funny.
Yeah, you were not kidding.
He's like, alright, time to watch some Overwatch.
Hey, we shot our gun!
We did!
We shot our gun!
You got the kill, Doki!
Doki, you got that.
I got a kill!
I shot my gun!
That was you.
And then I got stuck.
That's what happens when you stop hiding in bushes.
You died to a competitive Polish game.
I can't believe we did it, Doki!
We didn't end in dead last!
That's a huge win!
Against Fortnite pros?
Let's fucking go!
You know, if you think about it, we were going against all top pros.
Yeah, exactly.
That was so fucked up for us.
We ended in 18th or 19th.
That was so fucked for us, honestly, like...
I'm proud of us.
How we were treated there, like...
We just built Diffy.
Not last!
Woo!
Let's go, Doki!
Yeah, GG's!
Dori, thanks for dropping by super last minute to be my duo.
Thank you for considering me.
Had a great time.
I don't remember the last time I laughed this much when I was playing a game.
It's only been pain without you, Doki.
GG's!
No, I had so much fun, though.
Thank you for the games.
Yeah!
Thank you!
I can't believe... Oh my god, they went so...
We've been playing Fortnite for almost four hours.
Holy fuck.
Oh my... Doki, you're a certified Fortnite streamer now.
Oh god, no.
Guys, if you're... Guys, hey, as a certified Fortnite streamer, please use my creator code.
My creator code is supportacreatordokibird.
If you don't use it, then we're not gonna get a Doki skin.
Yeah, guys.
The more you use my creator code, the more chances I can get a Doki skin, guys.
Guys, just think about the Doki skin, guys.
GG's!
GG's, Dori!
I am gonna peace out now.
Alright, I'll catch you...
maybe not another three years.
Alright.
Bye, Dori-u!
Alright, bye, Doki!
Bye!
Alright, guys.
I'm tired.
I've been taking...
This is like an unintentional rest week.
But like, it's been nice, though.
Being able to, like, rest and relax this coming week and just chill.
It's been great!
I had a great time just chilling and hey, like just being relaxed.
Other than the Twitch Rivals part.
But...
But right after the streams, I usually just like...
Not checked out, but like I'm just zoned out and just like taking a nice break.
And touching grass now, so...
It's been good.
I think it's been very healthy for me, like mentally, too, and physically.
I've been walking a lot.
I've been... I've been walking a lot, so it's been really nice.
Hey, guys!
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on the YouTubes, but...
Like I said, for Twitch Rivals stuff, I stream on Twitch.
So, if you want to check and know when I'm going to be streaming on Twitch, please follow me on Twitter.
It's also DokiBird.
I think the majority of my socials is DokiBird.
If you want to support me via other means, feel free to...
Check my merch!
Buy my merch!
Or use my Gamersubs code or my Fortnite code!
There's so many different ways to support me!
Or hide it!
My new PC sub!
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for the subs.
Thank you all for the bitties.
Thank you all for the follows.
I really, really do appreciate it.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching Fortnite Twitch Rivals of us just fucking around most of the time.
I'm going to get some pho after this.
I'm...
I'm definitely going to get some pho.
I'm so hungry.
But as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!